Hello friends and neighbors. That's,
that's the nice way of doing it.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a way that you can deal
with a lot of legal shit online without
actually leaving your house.
Instead of going to a lawyers office,
making an appointment and
paying them a bunch of money,
you can be drunk and naked and still do
legal things as long as you're not too
drunk that you can't click the right
things, but you could start an LLC.
You can incorporate for just 99 bucks.
You can set up your family with a last
will for just 69 bucks or get a living
trust power of attorney and more
legal zoom gets the job done right?
910 customers would recommend the service
to their friends and family and when,
remember when we talk about nine out of
10 you got to always factor in the fact
that at least one at every
10 people is a fucking idiot.
Think of that and legal zoom
is pretty good that way.
They also have an a plus from the better
business bureau. That's pretty sporty.
Sounds good.
And if you panic,
legal zoom can connect you with a third
party attorney and you know they can set
it up so that like if you're on the way
and you're in the middle of filling all
this stuff out and you're like,
oh my God, I'm going to jail.
Legal Zoom will hook you up with a
lawyer thing. Clean up your mess,
but you don't have to worry about it.
Virtually everyone can do it. I'm on.
It was incorporated with legal zoom.
Brian formed a you here.
I can't breathe so good.
And my nose is kind of stuffy.
I have a tiny bit of a cold today.
Just a tiny bit.
So if it sounds like I'm breathing weird,
that's where that's coming from.
A legal zoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect you with a third
party attorney and provide you with self
help services. That's like lawyer
speak right there. Notice that part.
It's funny. Everything else on
the page is like normal print.
That part's bold and covered
in yellow because we didn't.
A strange time,
ladies and gentlemen,
no one believes anyone and you get a
special discount from listening to this
podcast.
Make sure you enter Rogan in the referral
box at checkout for more savings.
In the past 12 years,
over 2 million Americans have used legal
zoom and they've saved a ton of money.
Go get yourself some legal zoom.
Ladies and gentlemen, please for you.
And for those around you were
also brought to you by Lumosity.
And the Masa is one of my favorite,
uh,
of the sponsors because it's games for
your brain that actually can sort of
stimulate your brain in a way
where it will be more fit.
Does that make any sense? You know, they
say chess is really good for your mind.
It's really good for your thinking.
I don't know how they know that,
but apparently they do.
Well,
that thought process behind it has
been extended to a video games.
So if anybody ever starts telling you, hey
man, you should be playing video games,
it rot your brain.
Actually, they don't stupid.
They're actually good for your brain.
That's sounds ridiculous,
but it's not something people
want to hear because you know,
you look at a kid playing like you know,
battlefield,
whatever the fuck his name of
these games are now Titanfall,
that's supposed to be the new one.
Right?
Everybody keeps telling me about that one.
Yeah.
People were saying if you get
back into video games a stop,
stop trying to drag me in the
fucking hell of your existence.
But if you're in that hell,
you're actually exercising your brain.
It sounds crazy but it does,
but there's a way to do it where it's
designed specifically for your brain and
for your needs and that's
what Lumosity provides.
Lumosity is essentially
like a personalized gym
for your brain and when you
click the get started button,
they take you through a bunch of
different things you're trying to do like
memory,
like remembering patterns and locations,
associating names with faces,
keeping track of multiple pieces of
information and things along those lines.
You could check them off and
attention is another one.
Things like ignoring
distractions, blah, blah, blah,
speed decision making and time sensitive
situations and all these things.
You fill them out and then they dig,
create a program that's based on
the data that you've provided them.
It's really kind of cool. It's based
on the science of neuroplasticity.
What does that mean? Coming out
of my mouth, almost nothing.
I don't know what the fuck neuroplasticity
is. Apparently scientists do though,
and they like it.
They think it's good for you and the
thing about Lumosity that I enjoy is it's
fun. They're cool fun games. They're
like, you're working out your brain,
but it's actually enjoyable.
I would do it if it had nothing to do
with my brain if it didn't help my brain,
but I know it does help my brain
so it doesn't make any sense.
What I really am I just talking
shit I like. I enjoy it though.
Go to lumosity.com/joe
that's lumosity.com/joe Click
the start training button
and start playing your first game.
That's lumosity.com/joe it's really
interesting and I'm really excited that
someone came up with something like this.
Cause Chris Mcguire,
he's a good buddy of mine, used
to have a program for his, uh,
he had like one of those little Nintendo
game boys or some shit and it had a
program in it that was
designed specifically when I
was little handheld Jeremy's
and it was designed specifically for brain
games and I was always thinking, wow,
I need something like that,
but I'm not going to go out and
buy what a stupid little game. Boy,
it's just to get your brain games. So
I never did, but I do lose your mind.
Use used Lumosity and you should too.
lumosity.com/joe we're also brought to
you by [inaudible] dot com that's o n n
I. T. A human optimization
website. Who? Yeah,
man, I know Si. No, no, no.
I'm okay. I'm just, I'm,
I'm, I'm right now I'm not sick, but
I could be, you know what I'm saying?
Like I'm battling battling,
I'm fighting it back on at.com is a,
like I said,
a human optimization website and when a
Aubrey and myself tried to do with on it
is provide you guys with all the stuff
that we found that we use that we enjoy.
Things like strength and conditioning
equipment like kettle bells and battle
ropes, things that just provide an
awesome workout. Steel maces um,
they look like weapons
but they're not there.
What they are is this weird offset wait,
that's a long metal pole.
The big ball in the end of it,
it's very difficult,
weird to move around and when you move
it around you develop all these weird
muscles,
functional muscles,
muscles that work in an everyday
situation and also it helps your balance.
It helps your coordination.
What I'm interested in when it comes to
strength and conditioning things are all
things that improve athletic performance.
Things that you find when you watch
mixed martial arts fighters do their
training routines, like when they do
their strength and conditioning routines,
they very rarely do traditional
weightlifting activities.
You'll see a lot of battle ropes.
You'll see a lot of kettle bells.
He sees a lot of things along those lines.
So that's the kind of stuff
that we try to provide.
We try to provide things that actually
help the body move as a unit because as
people have gotten a deeper and deeper
understanding about strength and fitness,
one of the things they realize, it's
like things like curls, like bicep curls.
They don't make any sense.
Like you don't really do that in the wild.
You don't ever just pick
something up only with your Bicep,
you'd use your whole body and
then using your whole body,
you make everything strong and using
only an individual muscle. You Ha,
you run the risk of imbalancing yourself.
Any of those things that you do do
any kind of training exercise you do,
especially lifting weights.
Poolees go.
If you can go to a trainer
to go to someone who knows
what they're doing so you
don't get injured. It really sucks
getting injured when it's just ignorance.
So if you're about to embark on any
kind of weightlifting routine, you like,
God dammit, Joe Rogan, I'm
tired of being a weak bitch.
I'm about to get it together
to start out really light.
You get a lot of shit done being,
if you haven't done any work on it all
and you're really serious about it,
find out if you're serious about it.
But don't even go to a gym.
Do Body weight squats, pushups,
and sit ups. That's it.
Just write down how many you can do.
Just do them too.
You can't do them again and then write
it down and try and improve that number
and do it for a few weeks and
then blow your money on the gym.
Cause you know what sucks.
Sign up for a gym and then not doing shit.
And then that money just gets taken out
of your account every month and you're
like, I'm weak. Oh he can
lazy anyway on at.com.
Oh and and it, we sell all sorts of, um,
supplements and foods as well and buy
foods. I don't mean like groceries,
but we have thought about doing that too.
The idea of combining or a working in
conjunction with a local farmers that farm
organically is very exciting to us.
We've talked about that several times.
We're trying to figure out how
we could ever actually do it. Um,
but that might be in our future.
Just connecting you
maybe to local farmers,
connecting you to a farmers that are
raising their beef grass fed and in a very
ethical way.
Farmer farmers who are raising free
range chickens so you know you're,
you're not buying your chickens from
prisoners a little prisoner chickens.
That's our concern.
What we're trying to do it on it.
It's just connect you with everything
that we find beneficial in our life.
Hence the term human optimization.
Everything that we find that improves
cognitive function, that mood,
things that he,
that'll improve your immune system.
Things that are just whatever we find
like what's a good digestible protein,
hemp protein. Great. Where can we
get the best hemp protein Canada.
It's the only place. Okay, what's the
highest grade? This stuff, let's buy that.
That's our attitude on it.
Have you used the code Dean Brogan?
You will save 10% off any of the
supplements. The supplements,
the weird ones like new mood.
People are like, wait a minute,
is a supplement for your mood?
Yes.
It's been known for a long time that
five HTP can actually improve your mood,
your mood.
It actually helps your body
produce serotonin and new
mood create contains five
HTP and also contains l Tryptofan,
which also con converts to five HTP.
It's really fascinating stuff. Um,
and I'm, I might be wrong about those
things that are just said. How about that?
I mean,
I don't really know the fuck do I know?
I know what I've read though and I know
what, uh, what happens when I take it?
If you're concerned and you're like, what
if this is bullshit? Here's the deal.
At audit,
you have a first 30 pills.
You have a 90 day money back guarantee.
100%.
You don't even have to return the pills
to say this didn't work and you get your
money back. The last thing anybody wants
you to feel is like, this is a bad deal.
This is a bad situation. Try once you
don't like it, get your money back.
Who Cares?
But if you do like it,
we will promise you that we will sell
you the best quality ingredients that we
can find.
And being able to do it and distribute
it from one place like on it does,
allows us to put together combinations
that you just not going to see the, the,
the kind of dosages and purity that you're
going to get from Onnit products and
a lot of other ones because
it's just not cost effective.
So we have an advantage in that and
then we just sell it online like that.
So if you're interested,
check it out.
Use the Codeword Rogan and you will save
10% off any and all supplements. Okay.
Amber Lyon is here.
[inaudible]
Logan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Hey, Amber Lyon, last time we spoke
podcast was two months before the world
was supposed to get an end. It was right.
It was that big. Uh, December 21st,
2012 scare that everybody was so
terrified about, uh, you know,
we had people telling us for sure
some changes going to happen.
I had Daniel Pinchbeck on the podcast.
He told me for sure,
I go for sure something's going to happen.
December 21st,
2012 is absolutely without a doubt.
All markers point to that. Okay,
and here we are and where we are.
And then been like, ah,
I don't want to be me.
I don't want to be mean. It's
just, uh, you know, it's silly.
It's silly to think that you're going to
be the first guy ever to figure out how
the, what's going to happen.
You see a common, nobody
else does. You see a comment?
It's super easy if you're like a
ray Kurzweil guy and you're, um,
super scientific and very technologically
in tune and you know what the latest
technologies, so if he makes,
if Ray Kurzweil makes a
prediction about the future,
you've got to take it into consideration.
He's predicted a lot of things predicted.
The Internet search engine,
I believe he had something to
do with speech to text. He,
he had a part in creating
that. So that guy, I believe,
but when you're a hippie rider,
like Daniel Pinchbeck,
can you tell me it's going to be the
end of the world? I love your work, man.
Don't get me wrong.
I love that guy,
but I'm going to take it with a grain
that I should be really fair here.
Cause he did not say I was going to be
the end of the world. He did not at all.
He thought that there was going to
be some sort of a paradigm shift.
And by the way,
he might be right.
I'm all just talking shit here
because like who knows me.
Maybe I'll shift did take place. We're
just not quite aware of it yet. You know,
maybe it'll be looked at in history
like the French renaissance. Like what,
when did you know, when did uh, the
inquisition and exactly, you know,
did they feel it by the day? You
know, when did a World War II,
when it finally did end, when it
was d day, when did the dust settle?
When did everybody realized
what it incredible, insane,
impactful moment that had just lived
through it probably takes a few years,
you know, so maybe something happened
Internet wise in December 21st,
2012 we're just not aware.
Maybe that was when the NSA really kicked
it up a notch. You know? Who knows.
I mean, maybe it was something, it's just,
it seems like no one ever
really predicts the future.
Of course not,
and I believe that 2012 was a with
symbolic for an evolution of consciousness
that we're going through,
that we're finally starting to end this
madness as a species and an evolve to a
more conscious species that's more aware.
I just know even since the last
time I did your podcast show,
just how much awakening has
happened across the country.
I remember when I told you on the podcast
about how I suspected that potentially
my phone had been tapped or is it the
government was looking through my phone
while at the time people around me
thought I was crazy and paranoid,
but now we have the NSA revelations that
weight on it. This really is happening.
There's a reason why your phone
keeps shutting back on and you,
you may be in some foreign country,
but your geo tracker is working
perfectly even though you don't have self
service, which happens to me. A lot of
freaks me out. But um, but above all,
I think that we are shifting and people
are awakening. Uh, at this point.
I think you're right and I think
Janet Pinch specs right now. Oh,
I own an apology. I just was too
ignorant to see the shift. Yeah,
no,
I think there's most certainly something's
going on and I think a lot of it is
that younger kids today,
they have not been inundated with the
same sort of propaganda that we grew up
with and they're getting the Internet,
you know, from day one and they,
the exchange of information,
the way it's done today is not just
more accurate than ever before. Like,
like you know, like someone tells you
something stupid and you go watch,
let me Google that and everyone googles
it and then that ends nonsense and ends
a lot of nonsense conversations between
friends that would have gone for days
and days and days when I was a kid,
when I was a kid,
you had to go get a fucking encyclopedia
if you wanted to figure out whether
someone was full of Shit.
And you had go through the encyclopedia
and then you had a memorizing quoted.
You couldn't just pull your phone up and
stick it in their face and go, shut up.
Dubby you don't know what you're talking
about. As Encyclopedia Britannica,
we'd get like 12 episodes, so a through
z and just have to pour through.
Those would go door to door.
Remember that we'd go door to door
and try to sell them to you. Yeah,
we were the ones that bought them.
I grew up in the middle of the country.
We were suckers for all the
door to door solicitors.
Door to door.
Solicitors are so weird.
A charismatic person who's really good
at being slick and bullshitting you,
knocks on your door and sells you some
shit and tries to convince you to buy
some shit like you don't even,
you're not even in the store.
They're sending these creepers all around
the country just knocking on people's
doors and being slick.
He'd selling you vacuums and shit
or trying to save your soul. Those are
the best selling you their call. Yeah.
When you're sitting in the living room,
you know,
just relaxing and then someone knocks
on the door telling you everything about
your life is wrong and you need
instant savings. That only happen
been once in my whole life. And it was
when I was a little kid and I remember,
I think my grandfather was home.
I think my grandfather was
babysitting me and my sister, and uh,
someone came to the door. God, it was hard
to remember, but I remember it was like,
nope, sorry, get out. Sorry. Thanks.
Thanks. Bye. And there was so insistent,
just so foolishly insistent,
you know,
wanting you to know that if
you don't know about this man,
you're going to miss the end of the world.
They're predicting the end of the world.
It's just another 2012. It's another,
you know,
when those crazy people in San Diego,
I'll put on the Nike's and
killed themselves because
they thought the Hale Bopp
comment. People remember that. Yeah,
yeah, I remember that. But that was the
leader who had the, uh, he was bald. Yeah.
He looked very alienesque. Yes. I
forget homeboy's name. But yeah,
he was definitely a creeper.
I can't believe people followed him
based on his looks. He, he got me out.
Well, he was, uh, uh, I, you know,
I mean, look, if he could, Ron doss is
in the most normal looking duty there,
but you know, you listen to
them when you hear him talking,
you realize this guys is
about as real as it gets. The,
I would love to hear what this Hale
Bopp dude sounded like. You know,
maybe he was slick as fuck.
Maybe is a really good drawer.
Door salesman. You know, he didn't
he get them to castrate themselves.
Oh my God.
Take Castro
themselves to, or at least one of
them are. A couple of them did.
I think he felt like sexuality was a
imprisoning was probably some gay shit
going on.
He was scary how quickly
people can become,
and we'll make something like that and
like actually castrate rate yourself. Yes.
We say this when maybe he's correct areas.
There's the heaven's gate.
Maybe he's right. Yeah.
Name Marshall, Marshall.
You silly man. Yeah. Um, who
knows. Maybe he was right.
Maybe they're all in another planet
right now. We're the soccer's.
Maybe they're living in paradise,
you know, we don't know.
You just see their shells with
their Nike Symbolic Nike's. And I,
I never believed that we get the true
story of what was going on from the
government or from,
so you never
know. Maybe there was something
more to it. I don't know.
I don't think the governor,
they made up the castration thing
that is possible. Right. They do shit
like that. Have you ever been a part of a,
a story where you absolutely know
when you were working for CNN,
was there anything where you like,
I know that that's not how it happened.
I know it, what they're saying
on TV right now is nonsense.
Yeah, for sure. Uh, it happened
a lot of times. I think that,
especially across the media in general,
a lot of stories are just dumbed
down to the point that they just,
you lose the real essence
of the story. And, um,
and that happened for me in the situation
of Bahrain I talked about thoroughly
on your last show. But, um,
but sometimes I would see them
reporting things on air and,
and had watched documentaries that
they did and it was a stark contrast to
complete opposite from what
I'd seen on the ground.
What did they feel like the first
time you ever saw like bullshit,
the first time you ever knew?
Like,
I'm sure in the beginning when you
first started being a reporter,
you're probably very excited about the
prospect you work for CNN. Oh my goodness.
You know,
this is going to be amazing.
I'm going to do some hardcore
investigative journalism
and other countries.
What the first time you saw some bullshit,
what were you like?
What was your thought?
Uh, I just was so let
down Joe, because I was,
it just was like taking your
dreams and just crushing them. Uh,
one story at a time and that's kind of
how it happened to me there. It, it just,
it wasn't like one big incident happened,
but there was a little bit of censorship
with each story over and over and over
to the point that I realized that the
mainstream media was just misleading the
people.
And I was becoming a cog in the machine.
And so I'd gotten into journalism to help
people and tried to change this world,
but instead I was actually helping give
the station credibility and helping
spread what I believe to be lies.
And, and that's just a real,
just a devastating, uh, moment.
And it caused me a lot of
stress over the years for sure.
I'm sure. Um, it's,
is it a situation where the news
just becomes any other business,
any other organism, any other thing
that wants to grow and stay alive.
And the only way to do that is to
touch as many bases as you can,
spread out as far as you can and
collect as much money as you can.
And somewhere along the line you have to,
you have to make some deals.
Exactly. And I think you hit
the nail on the head, Joe.
And I think what's going on is that
a lot of these news outlets are,
like you said, corporations and their
main goal is to make money. And,
and that's what was
happening in the case of CNN.
They were taking money
from different governments,
pro US governments worldwide in exchange
for producing these documentaries that
made the government's look good.
It was, it was propaganda and um,
and bottom line was,
was to make money also.
I think there's other forces at play
trying kind of keep a pro us a agenda.
It had many of these outlets as well.
Wow. So you leave that,
you write your book,
which is excellent. We have a, we have
a copy of weight. It's back there.
We had so many books on the
desk and dated the literature.
But Molly crab, apple did
the cover. Right. And she has
oh yeah, she did some art inside the
book. Yeah. Molly is such a talented,
amazing artists.
It was really an honor
be able to have her work. Yeah. We had her
on the podcast. She was really cool too.
She's, she's free, you
know, like she's just,
when she talks like she's not
in hindered by, she's just free.
She is who she is and what she's really
talented, really interesting art to very,
you know,
she's one of those artists where you see
like one of her pieces and you almost
immediately recognizes her cause she's
got that very unusual distinct style.
Those faces that she draws.
She has this very unusual
and like compelling style.
And I liked that she adds
politics and do her art.
She's not scared to take that
jump. So much art has been,
you know, music, movies,
everything has just been dumbed down
in order to please these corporations.
And Molly is really joining
several artists and sticking
her neck out there and
willing to criticize people through
her art and criticize the system.
Yeah. And sort of expose things that
she doesn't, doesn't like. It's cool.
It's cool that, so you
write this book, you,
you put the book out and you did our
podcast and during the podcast we had a
conversation about psychedelics.
And um,
I mean I've had a lot of conversations
with people about psychedelics.
It's a question that
people ask all the time.
And I'm really fortunate to know a bunch
of people know the actual answers to
those questions. So you know, I have
this conversation and you, you say,
okay,
let me find out what the fuss is all
about and you get on the fucking raft and
go down to the jungle.
You like dove head in.
I've literally been tripping around
the world for the past year. So crazy.
So before the podcast,
nothing,
nothing the worst I had done,
which not even worse because
it's medicinal as we know,
but it was like smoked a
joint of marijuana in college.
Cause I grew up in the Midwest shell
and we were fed talk about propaganda.
We were fed propaganda from day
one about just say no to drugs.
And I even remember my grandmother
taped this episode of Oprah where this
scientist was on talking about
how Mtma eats holes in your brain.
It's later been debunked.
And that was proven that the
diagrams the scientists showed,
we're just showing cerebral blood flow
through the brain and the Mtma isn't
actually harmful.
But I mean that's the kind of
propaganda we were fed constantly.
And I remember my grandma would take all
these shows on 2020 and all these new
shows and bring them over to the house
and force me to sit down and watch all
this anti-drug propaganda.
So I associated all drugs as being
evil and just bad for you and Nadia.
Yeah,
it was funny way you described that.
That's the way to describe it.
The worst I ever did.
You smoke a joint like it's the eight
the knee jerk way of approaching it.
The worst I ever did.
So now I have to just completely retrain
my thoughts system because I've had 30
years of this propaganda and um,
and I've realized Joe,
that we are horribly mistaken and a lot
of situations in this country when it
comes to labeling things,
medicines, verse drugs,
and a lot of substances and natural
plants that natives have used as medicines
for thousands of years,
extremely effective medicines are
being called drugs and being labeled as
schedule one substances. And it's
just really unfortunate. Yeah.
It's unfortunate and in a lot of ways
the people that have never experienced
these things, it's impossible
to understand without trying it.
And I don't blame you
for being incredulous.
I don't blame you for being
skeptical and you should be,
people who are skeptical
are really important because
it puts out the debate and
whether they're correct or
whether they're incorrect,
it's always good having a bunch of
smart minds looking at it from different
directions, trying to
dissect it. And a big, uh,
a big part of our dissecting when it
comes to our culture is our law system or
legal system, what's legal and what's
not? What should be allowed to do?
What should you not be allowed to do?
And we have to figure out what it is
we're going to allow to influence that
legal system.
Because if it's corporations and the
people that are trying to protect prophet
man, you're going into a weird
fucking direction because guess what?
There's profit in that other stuff too.
You just,
you'd dummies just haven't tapped
into the psychedelic profit.
There's profit in what's going on in
Colorado right now is just starting to
realize, oh shit, there's profit
in this. Duh, people love it. You,
you just think that the only way to get
money is by selling fucking pills that
you make what you're doing as being a
hater and you try to hoard the market.
You're trying to control all the drugs
and there's some good drugs out there
that are pharmaceutical drugs.
There's,
there's fantastic medications that have
helped people with all sorts of ailments,
but that doesn't mean that you,
with your fantastic drugs at aid,
all these people should be able to
stop natural things like that's crazy.
And that's where as a culture we
got to put the brakes. We just,
it's not saying that pharmaceutical
companies are bad because they're not,
they're great pharmaceutical companies
are provided people with medications that
have vastly improved
their lives like Viagra.
There's a lot of people out there that
just wouldn't have had sex 2030 years ago.
It was,
it was over.
And then like a old picture that some
how or another summons up the courage to
get off the game and dust off his jeans.
He's back in there. You know, look,
there's, there's medication.
That's a bad one too.
This is medications for people
that have actual real diseases.
Not just can't get boners,
but you know there's,
there's really important medications,
but as a culture,
if there's one thing
that when people take it,
it almost universally gives
them a new perspective.
Almost universally makes them more
aware of their actions, more objective,
more sensitive, more work. It calms them.
It gives people a sense of
peace about leaving this life.
It gives you a sense of, I don't think
we know what we're talking about.
It gives you a sense of, I think there
might be some other shit besides this.
That sounds, that sounds just
like the heaven's gate cult.
That sounds just like anybody else that's
telling you that they know something
that other people don't know.
Most people were immediately
skeptical and they should be,
but this isn't nonsense.
This is some medicine that
helps human beings evolve.
And it's been here for thousands of years
and it's one of the measures as to how
weird we are today.
One of the reasons why we're so chaotic,
why we live on this momentum of his
incredibly ignorant pass and never stopped
to analyze it and change it. One reason
is the lack of these psychedelics.
It's like we're missing vitamin
scene. We have scurvy. I mean,
that's really what our culture is.
It's mad and loony because
it's not looking at itself.
Exactly,
Joe.
And I think what's going on is that
a lot of us have bottled up trauma
throughout our lives through childhood
especially. That's when I'll,
a lot of people get the
footprints of trauma in their
soul and, and just just, uh,
through PTSD, car accidents,
dangerous situations you're in,
and you keep this trauma bottled up
inside of your body without releasing it.
And it leads to this collective madness.
And,
and I think what we're facing as a society
is the limbic system of your brain is
a part of your brain that deals
with emotional processing.
And that's what psychedelics are
fantastic. It actually re, uh,
leading to neurogenesis,
restructuring the limbic system,
helping people get rid of
all of this trauma. And,
and really I think that the cause of most
of this madness is a collective limbic
system malfunction in society right now.
And I,
I believe that wars fighting,
I'll,
all of the environmental destruction
is just a symptom of this limbic system
malfunction.
And I think if we're able to actually get
in to the core of our insanity and all
these mental health disorders and society,
then we'll be able to really evolve
as, as a species. But I think that,
like you said,
the key to that are,
are these psychedelic medicines
because for a lot of people,
they're not able to actually overcome
that trauma without, without the help of,
of psychedelic.
I think you're, you're absolutely
right. And I think that this, um,
this weird world that
we live in right now,
we will make these incredibly beneficial
things that don't kill anybody illegal.
Um, it starting to come
to light now. And, um,
maybe that's what the 2012 thing was.
Maybe we just don't realize
it because we're a part of it.
But I think that people are so much more
aware of how bizarre and finite this
experiences and how many
people are running around
this experience acting as if
everything's normal. Well, this
is not normal. Nothing's normal.
We have madness at every turn.
We're still blowing each other
up with bullets were still shooting
missiles at each other. You know, we're,
we're fucking crazy with.
This is a weird species we are a part of.
And I think when you, when you look at
the possibilities and the potentials,
like how did we get to where we are?
Like what, what, what is, what's missing?
What's wrong with us? We
need spirituality. That's
what everyone always says.
We need religion.
And they're probably right.
You know what you get
from being a Christian,
what you get from like
true belief in any God and,
and if true belief in the power
of any enlightened, omnipotent,
being, omnipotent, being you, what you,
what you get is this feeling of humility
and this feeling of connection to all
that is right. You know, that's
what you get out of the, the,
the real religious experience.
And that's what you get from psychedelics.
And people don't want to hear that.
They want to hear that you're just trying
to escape reality. You're just weak.
You're just scared reality.
Oh, that's what you want to do.
And I see Amber Lyon,
well, you're telling me,
so you just fucking dive into your
fantasy world of dancing mice and fucking
Rodeo music. And you think you're so
fucking smart. Now you're going to Tom,
tell me how to live my life.
It is nearly impossible. It's impossible.
And psychedelics to escape reality,
whereas other drugs and I,
and I think that's one once again,
part of the propaganda, whereas other
drugs and alcohol make you escape reality.
Psychedelics actually
force you to sit down,
objective Lee and analyze your life and,
and solve your problems with a clear,
silent mind. And for many people,
it's the first time in their lives,
their mind is actually silent.
They're self critical.
Part of their brain is silent and they
can sit back and analyze portions of
their life and come up with solutions
to just make themselves a better person.
Yeah, that sounds ridiculous, doesn't it?
More ridiculous,
Joe,
is that something that grows on cow
poop all over the world and and,
and forests all over the world is,
is illegal and,
and something that is
manufactured by our own bodies.
DMT is also illegal.
So you're,
you're saying that my pineal gland should
be locked up in a cage, Huh? Yeah. Yeah.
It's hilarious. Your brain is a drug
factory of illegal drug factory.
It's literally like making saliva illegal.
If saliva was psychoactive,
it's so stupid. It turns from kind
of have a great joke about that.
[inaudible] was talking about
DMT being processed by the body.
So essentially said everyone's holding
like you're, you're all to arrest you.
They can arrest you for the components
of your own being. Wait a minute.
What if they could somehow or another
extract your blood and you had like a vial
of your blood, you're allowed
to walk around with that. Right?
I don't think anybody could stop you
for that. I'm Selena jellied. Yeah,
her and Billy Bob, right. Didn't they
cut each other crazy assholes. Um,
I don't think anybody can stop you,
but if you had like a little
little shot of your own DMT,
you would be in possession of
a schedule one illegal drug.
Like it put you in a cage for yeah,
for sure.
Hilarious. I don't think he can
extract it that way by the way. And I,
I can't think you enough, Joe, for, uh,
really sticking your neck out there.
And really, I know you faced
a lot of criticism for your
support of psychedelics.
Not really. No. It's been pretty easy.
I'm gonna be honest with Ya. Okay.
I'm sitting here given this like
heartfelt, no, you don't have to,
but I just think it's a great way to,
it's a great position to be in.
But I did take
you seriously that day in the podcast
when you told me mushrooms could change
the world and it really
planted a seed in my head,
which sprouted this journey that I've
been doing around the world investigating
these medicines. And, um, that never
would've happened. My, you know,
my life wouldn't be in
such the amazing state.
I feel like it is a now if
it hadn't been for you, uh,
having the gumption to,
to talk about this and start
this dialogue is our country.
Cause psychedelics have been so taboo,
especially in the mainstream. And I,
and I think you're really helping to
shift that consciousness nationwide.
I honestly don't think I am.
I think I'm just a part of the,
the whole thing itself. I mean,
it's very nice to try to give me,
I don't deserve any credit, nor
do I want any, uh, uh, I just, um,
I,
I'm a,
I'm shocked that more people don't know
about the experiences and I feel a duty
because I've been there.
It's just like if you and your friends
were starving to death and you found some
food and the test, and you're like,
guys, come here, come here, come here.
I found the food.
Would you want all this credit
for foreign enough food? No.
You'd want your friends to have the food.
That's how I feel like. Feel like, uh,
you know what? What we're all experiencing
right now is we is a wait, what moment?
The whole coach culture is
going, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What? Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait a minute.
The NSA is listening to my fucking emails.
They're listening to my voicemails.
They're the reading my emails.
I don't do anything wrong,
man. Come on. I'm a fucking
insurance salesman. And then,
and then people go, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What marijuana makes how much
in fucking taxes for Colorado?
They make how much we know we're running
out of fucking money for schools and we
could pay for that with weed,
but be,
and people got to smoke the same amount
of weed anyways, statistically proven.
What the fuck is going on?
When you look at [inaudible],
we're going to go into Syria. Wait,
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa.
What the fuck are we doing this? Wait,
what moment is we're all a part of this?
Wait, what moment? You're a big part
of this? Wait, what moment? Yeah.
You're a big part of it by sticking your
neck out about by rain and about CNN
and about, you know, working
for a corporation and being
honest about it, you, you,
you stuck your neck out about it.
We're all just,
we're all forced into this reality.
We didn't ask to be here.
We were, you know, hey,
can you give birth to me so I can grow
up in the 21st century and fake knowns?
She's, this is what you get. You got
nobody asked you, this is what you get.
And I think all of us realize that
that was the same for our far parents.
It was the same for our grandparents.
It was the same for everybody.
And nobody hit the brakes. Nobody had the
wait what moment where they went, wait,
wait, wait, wait, what
the fuck are we doing?
Everybody just kept going and then had
heart attacks and died and taught a bunch
of nonsense to their kids.
And they went and they had heart attacks
and died teaching a bunch of nonsense
to their kids. And then the internet
came along and that's the way,
what moment and the wait, what moment?
The real tipping point is people like you.
People like me, people like anybody
that's a part of the, wait, what moment?
That might be my new t shirt and
Peters. It's great. Yeah, we had him
on the podcast. He's fucking crazy.
He doesn't,
he's very supercharged fan.
He's passionate about about
what he's doing and he's
part of the moment for sure.
Because in some ways, in some ways
he's part of the problem. Yeah,
I liked the guy a lot,
but he, his uh, I believe,
I agree with him on a lot of what he says,
but what I don't agree with them
about is environmental concerns.
If he doesn't have very many
environmental concerns, he's is,
as long as people are making
money, he's fine with it. You know?
That's unfortunate.
Well,
it just feels like it's just a few
small spots and don't worry about it.
So a couple of spots get fucked up. We're
going to have regulation. Yeah. We seen,
can you say a BP oil spill? Like that's
what happens. Well, it's interesting. I,
like I said, I really liked the guy
and I'd like a lot of his thoughts,
but he was, he believed in somethings
that I agree with. Like the no,
banks are too big to fail and they should
have like let the banks fail and that
at the end of all that,
obviously I'm no economist by
any stretch to the imagination,
but I agree with his reasoning that
any system that doesn't work should be
allowed to fail. And there's
nothing that's too big to fail.
But then when we started talking
about BP, you know, it's like,
I think personally like he was talking
about if BP went under like what that
would do to everybody and I said,
well I think what they did is way worse
than a cut a company going on there.
What they did was they ruined a part of
the ocean are really big part for a long
time and it might still be ruined.
It might be ruined forever. I mean,
who knows what kind of devastating
effect it had on the marine life,
Dolphin life. If you had to put
all the death that was caused,
all the destruction that was caused,
all the people that are getting sick,
trying to clean that place up.
If you had to really put a number on it,
of course they shouldn't
be around anymore.
But his argument was that BP was too big
to fail. And I found that fascinating.
So disgusting.
Joe.
I was down there covering it for a month
in New Orleans for CNN and I'm a huge
fan of the ocean.
I an avid scuba diver and um,
and just witnessing the oil, oil soaked
pelicans diving down into the oil,
actually having the water be your enemy.
We were on the boat and it was like 90
degrees outside and when the water would
splash up on us, instead of it being
refreshing, I had to wipe it off my body.
Like it was a poison.
And I was so horrific that that month
of covering that I've even had to,
you know, through my
psychedelic experiences, I've
even processed some of that,
some of those implicit memories,
these horrific memories
of that spill that we're,
we're stuck in the back of my son.
Yeah. And people could say,
oh, she's being manager, Matt,
I'll Peter Schiff, you. Oh,
so really, you poor baby, you have
a hard time. Cause the dirty water,
the dirty water made you cry.
The dirty water fuck with your brain.
But it's gotta be a weird moment as a
reporter being one of the first few people
that's allowed to sort of go out there
and boats and experience it and report on
it that you, you know, you got
a pretty big responsibility.
You're getting to see some
shit that people, most people,
most people are not going to go to it.
Most people in this country that are
experiencing and are experiencing it
through you or through someone like you,
that's their reporting on it.
That had to be pretty intense.
That,
and also seeing the distraction man can
cause on this earth firsthand was just
really,
uh,
just you see that kind of feeling because
when you look out and as far as you
can see,
you just see oil and crap and in this
beautiful ocean just ruined like that.
I mean, it just took a matter of days.
Uh, you just really realize, wow,
we really do have the capability
to completely destroy this planet.
And it gives you,
especially journalists,
delete and extra sense to make sure
to cover more environmental issues and
investigate these corporations because
when left to their own devices, uh, you,
you see what happens.
Yeah.
You can't allow some thing that lives
off profit to not have oversight.
You just can't. You
can't, it'll just, it'll,
and it'll probably kill the oversight
guy. They probably figured out, I mean,
that's what happens. Yeah. You know,
it happens in a lot of environments
where there's a lot of money involved.
Things get real fucking squirrely.
People just disappeared. Yeah.
Whenever Johnny saw, well, we'll
just get rid of Johnny. I mean,
who knows how many people have
disappeared right in here. The reasons.
I mean this is probably, well I
don't know if there's a, uh, it's,
I dunno if there's a running number,
was probably a few of them that just,
they got away with. I mean, if
they're doing it for this long,
getting rid of people to
get in the way of profit.
Of course people have done that.
If people are willing to,
that's the weird thing
that people don't want to,
I'm in a lot of folks that no
nonsense type folks that I, I, I,
I categorize certain types of skeptics
and there's some no nonsense skeptics.
They don't even realize that they're
sort of almost in a religion and their
religion is debunking everything.
Their religion is calling bullshit.
They love calling bullshit and even
calling bullshit when it doesn't even make
any sense. Like when you start talking
about false flag attack, oh, bullshit,
bullshit, bullshit, bullshit.
They love calling bullshit.
Do you really think that the government
would plan an attack and blah, blah, blah,
or this or that, or lifted. And
then you start proposing, okay,
well what do you think happened when they
did that in the Gulf of Tonkin? What,
what do you think happened there?
Ah,
there's
nothing. They can't say anything. You know
what they did? You know what they did?
They lied and they got people
to go to war because of the lie.
Like it's been done.
Human beings not,
I'm not blaming the current administration
for what happened during the Vietnam
War. I'm saying human beings
have shown time and time again.
They're willing to do that.
They're willing to lie.
And who knows how many lives are
going to be co wasted in this lie.
But they're more than willing to if it,
so yeah.
Oh, for sure. You know, and that's even
a situation I had, uh, when I was at CNN,
a lot of people had known that lies,
we're going on air and,
and that this was happening, but they
continued to work there for money,
you know, and they, I
mean, it just, like I said,
sometimes money comes first.
Yeah.
Unfortunately or fortunately because
the good thing about what's going on in
Colorado and Washington is money.
That's the good thing.
And if money truly does come first, maybe
that will be a big part of the shift.
Maybe the people insistent on their
freedom or are one part of it.
But then along the way,
the money people get cooptive as well
because they become addicted to that
marijuana money and they won't let the
government shut off the pipe. Exactly.
I mean, it does seem to
make sense. And so, um,
you have this one experience. You, you'd
go down there, you take the IOWASCA.
How many,
how many different trips did you go on?
Um, I w I did seven,
so I, um, I went down,
I, uh, I was feeling really
stressed out and life.
I just had a bunch of crazy shit happened
to me throughout my career and it was
just one, uh, experience after the
other and I just hadn't had time. Uh,
I had this bottled up trauma like so
many of us are carrying around. I,
I hadn't had time to process it. And
so I remember you telling me, um,
I had written you after the podcast about,
uh,
mushrooms because I
looked up silicide been,
and I could not believe all the lies
we've been fed about magic mushrooms. How,
I mean,
I mean silicide been is single handedly
one of the most incredible healing
chemicals for the brain. Uh, some people
call it 30 years of therapy in one night.
And so I looked up psilocybin and then a,
you,
I'd written you and you'd
recommended, uh, trying IOWASCA.
And so I kind of kept that
in the back of my mind.
And then when I got to this point
in the spring where I felt like, um,
I was having so much anxiety,
constant butterflies in my stomach,
I couldn't sleep,
I couldn't eat.
It was like I was in an
anxiety purgatory. And, um,
and something in my brain.
I just remembered that email and I
remember reading all this positive, uh,
research and studies about a IOWASCA
and other psychedelics helping with, uh,
anxiety and post traumatic
stress disorders.
And I just knew I had it had to go down
to the jungle and I didn't even prepare.
I just bought a ticket and went down two
days later because I was so out of it
at the time that I didn't
even have time to pack.
I remember pulling into
Los Angeles International
Airport and parking lot. See,
and I don't even know how I
found my way to the airport.
It was just like this magnet was
drawing me to the jungle. Um,
and because I was so anxious and
had so much adrenaline rushing in,
in so many flashbacks happening that
it was really hard to even drive. Um,
and I was sitting in the
parking lot scene and I'm in my,
the back of my car and I'm packing this
backpack I find in my trunk and I'm
maybe a dirty sock under the seat and
Oh wait, I'm headed to the jungle.
I think I need a flashlight.
So I went into my glove box and I found
this little menu readers that senior
citizens get the, my grandma
ordered from me on Qvc, um,
and through that in my bag and just grab
this backpack and was standing there
waiting for the bus. Joe. And I remember
looking up at this Guy Thinking,
oh my God, if there's a rock
bottom in life, I've, I've hit it.
And, um, and just thinking that
there's, there's no way out.
Like I Iowaska,
I mean this is my last hope.
And um,
and so I get on the plane and I'm,
I'm heading down there,
um, and just, uh, you know,
looking over the jungle,
I was by myself.
I didn't know where the hell I was going.
I just found this center online really
quickly and I'm sitting there drinking a
glass of wine, looking out it just
this vast array of Amazon jungle.
I'm completely unprepared.
I don't know what the hell I'm doing.
I don't even know what Ios get is.
I didn't read up on it beforehand.
I just felt a calling. It was
weird. A lot of people tell me this,
you feel a calling to do it.
It's like the medicine telling you it,
it can heal you. And um, and then, uh,
and then we landed and I remember,
um,
I had my sunglasses on still cause I,
I was just a mess.
And I remember seeing this guy sitting
behind me and he kept looking through the
airplane seats at me and I was like,
what is this creep doing?
Like I must look like shit because
he will not quit looking at me.
And right when we get up, he comes
up, he's like, are you Amber Lyon?
And I was like,
fuck,
like the only time in my life where I
don't want to be recognized where I want
to completely disappear from the world.
This guy, uh, this guy recognizes me.
So, um, we ended up becoming good friends
who's now my business partner. But um,
but uh, yeah, the whole plane was all
headed to this same retreat center,
which was about a two hour ride
into the Amazon and, and so,
um, it was a small jet, but
yeah, no propellers. Yeah,
propellers freaked me out because I'm
always worried maybe a bird's going to get
caught in there or, you
know, so it was, uh,
it was just a small jet about 20 seats
and everyone on there were gringos.
So when we're never, you go to Iquitos,
Peru, and you see Gringos, you know,
that they're most likely there
for IOWASCA tourism. I mean,
why else would they be
there? And uh, and so, uh,
so we flew into ketosis and then it was
me and five guys and they were all going
to the same center. So I was really
relieved because I was like, okay,
at least I know these guys and
they seem fairly trustworthy.
And then we got on a boat and traveled
two hours up the Amazon and just entered
in this area of forest where you just saw
this little hut and it was the name of
this healing center. And,
um, and yeah, that's it.
And that was, um, that was really
creepy. I guess. I was like,
this looks like a place that people don't
return from, but it, but at that point,
I,
I knew that I had no choice,
like I had to try this
medicine. And so, um, so,
so I went, you know, I just thought
this fear was resistance to healing.
And so I, I dealt with
the fear and, and dove in,
that's like a scene in a movie.
Yeah, it was, it was,
um, it was really, yeah,
the new altered states could be about
a woman who goes to the Amazon that was
like, that would be, you know,
the whole thing from grabbing like dirty
socks and you just throw them in your
bag, whatever you got, just
what a flashlight running,
leaving your car behind.
And, and then I had to, you know, now that
a couple of people would recognize me,
I had to kind of try to put myself
together when I really wanted to just lay
back and just, just be, and um,
then at that point I had to,
I was like, I can't let these people
know like, why I'm really here. You know,
I'm just here as a journalist. I'm just
here to write about these medicines.
I don't really need them. And,
um, and really the, you know,
I was putting on this,
this face that everything was all
good and I was here journalistically,
but really inside I was
just torn to shreds and,
and really hoping to God that
this medicine was going to work
well. That's where the skeptic
would come in and say, well,
you have to realize this
is a placebo effect.
The psychosomatic nature of your
incident led you to have a very stressful
reaction to what was
essentially just hallucinations.
And you've connected all this spiritual
Mumbo jumbo will bullshit to you,
tripping your balls off.
Well, I would say the
science disagrees with them.
And then thousands and
thousands of anecdotes.
There's not a lot of scientific research.
Do you have to also go with the anecdotes,
which I think are just as powerful.
But the science actually shows that
when you go to these IOWASCA churches in
Brazil, like the UDV or
Santo Dom a church, they, uh,
the members of these church who drink
Ayahuasca regularly actually have improved
levels of Serotonin in their brain.
So a lot of these healers believe it
actually restructures your serotonergic
system, which allows you to part
with this depression and anxiety.
It's also,
um,
some Shamans I've dealt with say that
what the IOWASCA does as it gets in your
soul and gets rid of these
dark energies and, um,
painful events that have been holding
you back and that might manifest
themselves in anxiety or
depression or in bodily pain.
And so if you, if you look
at that research, there is a,
there are thousands of
anecdotes of people saying,
I'm including myself saying that this,
this medicine, uh, worked for them. And,
and I, you Osca is a medicine.
It behaves like a medicine.
The more you take of it.
Uh,
the less you need and actually behaves
like a medicine should and cures,
uh, whatever's wrong with
you. Um, for me it did.
It doesn't track spiritually.
You are,
you are your connections that
you've made in your mind. It resets
them.
And then oftentimes that is how we react
to things is based on our connections.
You know, our past can really
completely flavor our future because it,
it changes the way you behave and
the way you interact with people.
And when you do that,
you change the nature well,
you change the nature of the
interactions that you had with people.
Do you change the directions that
things are going to go in? You know,
I mean many people, if you put them in
one situation, um, no fight takes place,
but many other people,
you put them in the exact same situation
and it turns into murder. Yeah.
I mean that's,
it's really,
it's a lot of it is our connections
to how, what, what we've,
we've made in our life and
we don't realize how much
those sort of hold us back
until a psychedelic experience.
And to the,
to the Naysayer people like
your very important, you know,
the skeptical people that say,
oh, it's just the hallucinations.
You're attaching all this shit to it.
This is what you have to realize.
And I've said this so many times, I don't
even wanna hear myself say it again,
but it's, it's really important
whether or not it's a hallucination,
whether or not it's all in
your imagination or whether
or not you were really
having an experience.
We are meeting divine wisdom and it's
giving you advice and love and showing you
a new way.
Whichever one of those it is,
it's the exact same experience.
You are having the exact same experience.
So it doesn't matter if you choose
to look at it one way that it's a
hallucination,
it's a product of your imagination.
Or if you choose to look at it the other
way and say, Oh my God, I'm, I'm, uh,
meeting the divine wisdom of the universe
and now I'm humbled by this and I'm
going to be a better person because of it.
This experience is exactly the same.
It's on how you choose to apply
it to your life. You know,
just people don't want the no nonsense
people. They don't want to be fools.
They don't want to talk about,
they don't want to be the heaven's gate
people chopping their balls off and
wearing the purple Nike's.
They don't want to be that guy.
So because of their limiting, there's
this, it's almost like an ego thing.
Like they know they don't want to fall
prey to some foolishness and then have
other people pick apart. You know what
they've done? Like, look at this dummy.
He thought that Colin had taken Iowasca
is going to connect them to the universe.
Yeah.
All Right Bob.
Wait a go pow.
You know the ego fighting
back and resisting entering
that dimension whatsoever.
If you go there,
right
and then you think it's nonsense,
then we should talk because I got to
know what your thought process on it is
because everyone that I know that's had,
especially the DMT experience,
which have you had,
have you done that yet?
Uh, no. But I had an Iowaska experience.
It was very similar to what people have
described having when they smoked DMT.
I'd been fasting for five days
and had this Kambo frog medicine,
which really detoxifies you.
So I was ready just to absorb the DMT and,
and I went where a lot of people have
described with smoking DMT on the Iowasca.
Well
it's for folks who don't know Iowasca
and DMT essentially are the same drug.
It's just a DMT is not orally active
cause your brain produces your body rather
produces something called model,
a amine oxidase,
which breaks down
dimethyltryptamine in an oral form.
So they figured out how to do something
where they have the plant.
One plant has DMT in it and
another plant has a harming,
which is a natural m a o inhibitor.
And they mix the two of them
together and break it down.
And no one knows how they figured
out how to do this either.
This has been done for thousands
and thousands of years.
The fact that in the hundred
plus thousand plants,
they chose these two
what's the most effective?
And they use different ones in other
cultures too though, right? The right,
the one thing,
different types of plants that have the
same sort of ingredients like different
plants that are very rich and DMT
and plants that are very rich and uh,
and harming or some something sooner.
You can mix different types of,
of leaves as long as they have DMT with
the Iowasca because what the Iowasca
does is just help your body absorb that
DMT. So, uh, particularly where I went,
they use Chacruna leaves,
uh,
and mix that with the Iowasca that
they had growing on the ground.
So we actually got to watch them make
it, which was pretty exciting. Um,
knowing that I had
no idea what I was in store for,
you probably thought
it was going to be like a
little bit of bullshit. Right?
I,
I was so desperate at that point that I
didn't know what to expect. Like I said,
I just was a calling to go down
there and, and do it. And, and, um,
some Shamans I've talked to said that the
medicine often does that to people who
really need it. They just feel
this desire to go down and try it.
And they just feel this. They just
know that it's going to help them.
And that's what,
that's what I had.
It sounds like bullshit.
I know this,
unless you've actually had a real
psychedelic experience and then you know,
any of them, whether it's a strong
mushroom experience or whatever it is,
when you realize like, oh, okay, no one
knows what the hell's going on like this,
this, this shouldn't might very well
be calling you. It very well might be.
And, and there was a, so when
I got there, it's just me in a,
and about 12 dudes and that's
it, right? Yeah. So once again,
I wouldn't recommend, uh, for females.
I recommend you always go down with
a friend. Don't follow my example.
This is the reason a very, um, uh,
responsible amber lions in the disclaimer.
I just don't have a high level of fear,
so I was able to go down by myself.
But every weapon, do you have
prison shank? Nothing. No.
No weapon.
No days.
Or could you imagine the showman comes
up and starts like blowing Agua Florida
on you and you just get away
from them when you have a
hammer? Everything looks
like a nail, but I'll get it.
I mean, I had, I did have a bad
experience with my showman the first, uh,
the first night and that's why I don't
recommend women go down or an experience
where you Shama is trying
to hook up with you. Um, no,
he just inappropriately touched
me during the ceremony and now
the time I didn't know
that it wasn't okay. And I,
well, what do you, because you're under,
you're under the influence
of the Iowa Scott. Oh,
so you were in the middle of
tripping. Yeah. He touched you.
Yeah.
So to tell you the whole story,
so this was our first night really
doing the medicine I, the night before.
They had just given us just a little
bit so we could kind of get used to the
creepiness cause the whole thing
is creepier in this yogurt,
in the middle of the jungle
laying on these yoga mats,
you have this huge bucket next
to you just to take out there.
I mean imagine that Joe going
into that each night and um, and,
and so the whole thing is super creepy
so you have to get used to that.
And then the next night we actually
were able to take our full dose and of
course there's the bed that we laid on
and our buckets cause you just violently
vomit.
Most people do kind of out of both.
That's all you get for a bucket.
I think I would need a bigger boat.
Oh there I am laying right there.
So I was kind of in the front,
the circle. And you see there's about
12 people around this year at ESC, um,
area. And, uh, and with
the bucket in the vomiting,
they actually call it getting well
because you're pulling out all your toxins
and all this negative dark energy
that Western medicine tends to ignore.
The IOWASCA is actually getting to the
bottom of, of the core of that. So,
so they consider this violent vomiting
and um, some people out the other end, uh,
to be really good
healing diarrhea.
I think it's appropriate for a woman to
say that. I don't know. That's ridiculous.
Okay. So people were taking massive shifts
and they were vomiting part of life.
It's part of like you can't deny it.
I am.
So I was the first one all day.
We'd been sitting around the table at
lunch like how much are you going to take?
The most you could take was a cup and
that was like the absolute send you to
another universe amount. And I'm,
and were all nervously like, okay,
well maybe we'll just take half a cup.
All of us together.
We'll take a fourth cup.
And I went up there and I was the
first one to go up in this group.
And something just told me, you need
to take the full cup. So I said, okay,
I'll take a cup. And I looked
around all the guys in the circle,
we're just like, oh shit. Cause now
they had to take a cup too, you know,
they didn't want to
seem like [inaudible] and uh,
and so I drank this mixture and it tasted
like coffee mixed with cough syrup to
the point where you just
like gag right away.
And then went and sat back
on my mat and then, uh,
about 20 minutes later it started
taking effect and it just,
the noise of the crickets outside in the
jungle got louder and louder and louder.
And I could hear people all around me
just violently getting sick to the depths
of their soul, like, oh, like
gut wrenching, throwing up and,
and I just laid back. And, and then
where are they diarrhea? Do they use
the other bucket? I have a photo of it.
There's actually a bathroom. Um,
make it to the breath. It's funny,
like the diarrhea. There it is.
And that was when it was clean. I,
I gotta be honest with you sometimes
I've gone in there and it was the floors
were brown.
It just slipped
or they didn't, didn't care.
They were tripping their shit.
I would just go out into the jungle
and a lot of people did, but,
but some people that would suck,
some people they were scared to,
they had to have armed guards outside
and in Garth's watching people,
cause people would go and walk away into
the jungle and you don't want to get
lost in that state.
So that was something that people
were really cognizant of. And,
and so that's why a lot of people went
into the bathroom. That was their fight.
Um, yeah, it was, uh, it
was really powerful. Joe,
like I just laid back and um,
next thing I know, I just heard,
here we go and then it's that,
here we go.
And then Bam, I saw all
this shit, sacred geometry,
which is potentially the language of
communication of the universe. Um,
I saw all these ones and
zeros going across the screen.
I heard the sound of coins just
clicking clinking, clinking.
I flew through a timeline of my life.
It was almost like the IOWASCA was trying
to get to know who I was and so I saw
pictures of me pop up on this three
d timeline from when I was 12, 10.
Then when I was born, and then a photo
of my parents before they conceive me.
And then, um, and then all of a
sudden on this big cement wall,
almost like the wall behind you,
it's spray painted the words
anxiety really, really big.
And right then the medicine was telling
me that it had figured out what was
wrong with me and yeah. And it was
literally because I didn't know,
I couldn't pinpoint it.
I couldn't pinpoint because at the time
my thoughts were reasoning so much,
I couldn't really figure
out what was wrong.
And that's often a symptom of people
who have post traumatic stress disorder,
posttraumatic stress disorder symptoms.
There's just so much going on that you
can't even stop to think about, okay,
what could have caused this?
What's happening you,
you just can't even stop to think.
And I'm in the Iowasca clearly
told me your problem is anxiety.
And then right then I laid back and I
felt it crawling through my veins and up
into my head. And it almost
felt like a fizzing in my head.
And at that point it was telling me laid
back, we're going to take care of this.
And I felt like there were,
um,
and this is a common vision that there
were all of these like thousands and
thousands of little beings
are elves on my body.
And they were literally going through
myself one by one and reshaping them and
perfecting them.
And the medicine above all just told
me to just lay back and let it work.
And um,
and then I laid there for probably about
an hour and then had a really powerful
vision after that of this like being this
like fairy type thing coming up to me
and then sucking out this dark energy.
And I saw all of this energy flowing
out of my body, these dark, uh,
I guess you'd call them spirits of people
who I'd interviewed over the years.
And what it was telling me was that as
a journalist been absorbing all of this
pain and had it just stored in my body.
And that was one of the things that was
manifesting itself in the post traumatic
stress disorder.
And so it was literally just sucking out
all of this dark energy that was shaped
in the forums of people I'd interviewed
and their faces over the years.
And um, and once it finished, I just
felt like such a sigh of relief and like
a ton of bricks had been taken off off
my shoulders. And yeah,
it was so powerful. And,
um, and, and I realized to, what it had
told me is that like journalistically,
some journalists,
and this is true with doctors and,
and other people who deal with,
are faced with trauma a lot is it some
journalists are able to put up a brick
wall and you kind of do your
story and then you move on.
But for me to really understand
what I was reporting on,
I had to almost become the people I was
interviewing to really feel their pain,
to understand who was telling the truth.
What they were going through.
And that happened to me so many
times using submersion journalism,
but I didn't realize at the same time I
was also absorbing a lot of their pain.
Especially I'd done a lot of stories on
sex trafficking, child sex trafficking,
a lot of stories on drug addiction,
oxycodone, oxycontin addiction.
And when I'd sit with these people and
watch them shoot up oxycontin pills,
I was absorbing that pain because I would
sit and intensely watched them to try
to feel why are they
doing what they're doing.
And so all of this was just stored in my
body and the IOWASCA was taking it out.
It seems like it would be really
beneficial for soldiers. Yes,
there are soldiers who've gone down.
Uh,
some scientists have actually followed
them down into the jungle and all 12 of
them that went,
came back reporting improved symptoms
of post traumatic stress disorder.
Because what I WASC is really good at
doing the way to cure post traumatic
stress disorder is you really need to
get into your subconscious or you have
these memories locked in there that
you don't even remember. You remember.
And you need to be able to
process them with a sound mind,
to detach the fear that's
associated with those memories.
So that next time anything that
triggers that memory comes up,
you're not flooded with
fear. Um, so for example,
anytime a soldier might hear a loud
noise that reminds them of the time they
were shot at in a tank,
and that's why they're,
they face this adrenaline rush
or a panic attack. Or for me,
it became even seeing,
um,
I'd had several bad experiences with
police officers as I was covering the
protests. And so when I would
see police or their, their guns,
I'd start to get really anxious.
And so for me it was just a matter
of processing those memories.
And that's what the Iowasca
is so beautiful at doing.
I had stuff come up that I didn't even
remember I remembered and that had been
trapped in there causing me this
anxiety for the majority of my life.
And um,
and the IOWASCA was,
was key to helping me access.
That's so fascinating.
That's very different than
a DMT experience. I really
have to do it because the,
the DMT experiences,
so it's so overwhelmingly alien that you,
what what you get out of it is,
it's,
it's really hard to hold on to anything.
Like you don't see like anxiety,
you don't see, like, at least for me,
for me, there's, there's nothing written,
there's everything is
implied and everything is
projected through these things
to you and everything you see
is impossible to describe.
There's no words written down. It's
just way too big. It's way too crazy.
And the DMT Flash,
I supposedly as far more intense,
but it sounds like the Iowasca
journey is much more introspective.
I find a very, uh, attractive
and, and now he, Wasco takes control and
just starts working its magic on you and,
and really getting in there and, and
healing you whether you like it or not.
And for some people it's
terrifying because I,
I've witnessed people screaming and
running out into the lawn and the child's
pose saying, God, make this
stop or someone make it stop.
Because for some people really getting
in there and seeing what they're really
about because they've been living this
personality, this mask their whole lives,
they've not been their true selves as
a coping mechanism to deal with society
when they're finally faced with the
mirror held up magnifying your true self
times 40 they can't handle
it. Um, but for me personally,
I found it to be extremely therapeutic
because I had so much chaos going on in
my head that I couldn't figure out
what was even at the root of that. And,
and the IOWASCA allowed me to,
to really figure out what
was causing my problems.
Well,
the idea that a drug experience could
change based on your intent going into it
seems for a lot of people for postures,
but when you take into account that
what these drugs are doing, essentially,
like what, what you're trying to
do when you have an IOC experience,
it has a big impact on what kind of
experience that you actually have.
Because if you try to fight it in any way,
if you try to wrestle with it in any
way, we try to resist. And No, no,
that's not what I'm like. I'm like
this. If you try to argue with it,
it will fuck you up.
Sideways Mushrooms. Well,
DMT will, marijuana will.
If you eat a pot Brownie,
eat a really strong pot Brownie and
try to try to argue with it. Oh my God,
you're fucked man. I mean, that's
what a bad trip is really all about.
It's about your intent going
in, so you got lucky. You,
you went into it with a perfect
intent mean it knew this crazy bitch.
Just threw her shit into a bag. Just
jumped. She got a flashlight to read with.
Like you're the fucking jungle.
You got a little bit,
you didn't even get an extra
battery stuff. Flashlight. I bet.
No, I didn't. I had to
borrow all I had to go to,
you know the guy sleeping next
to me and borrow socks from him.
So embarrassing some blog
I had. No, it was mosquito
spray. I was just eaten alive.
I think I brought you a
photo of my spider bite.
I woke with up a woke up with one day.
It was the size of a quarter when I
woke up and then it just started growing
throughout the day or about the site.
There it is. Oh my God, that's terrible.
And I'm sitting there, I'm
like, wait for two hours.
I know shit for two hours away from
any state of medicine and I'm just,
and it's just watching it grow and
grow and grow a not necessarily,
but it did stop growing. Thank
goodness. Wow. But, um, but yeah,
there are definitely some amazing insects
there that would scare the fuck out of
me. I'm terrified of. There
you go Joe. That's uh,
my roommate Jason shot that photo and
those were just some spiders around around
the house.
Oh God dammit.
So I go down there and after you
recommended for me to do, I'll ask,
I'm sitting at the table in time,
Joe and I'm, people are like, well,
why are you down here?
You know, I'm like, oh,
well a good friend of mine
had suggested to go and,
and I had mentioned your name and they're
like, put Joe just never done. I was,
and this is before my first drink
and I'm thinking, what the hell?
I'm all the way in the Amazon.
You should go to Mars.
Totally go to Mars. How come you
haven't, how come you haven't tried it?
Because I've never gone down
to the jungle. I've only done,
I've done DMT seven
times. No, no, that's it.
As far as the diamond field trip to
me and experience and uh, I just,
I've never had the time, never had
the time to travel down to the jungle,
but I'll definitely do it.
And I think too, it's dependent on if
you really need the healing, you know,
I mean the Iowasca knows who needs
healing and she does it all use it.
I do think so. Very much
so. But I do think too,
if you don't actually go down
there with an intent for healing,
then it may not work. Which
happened to someone who, uh,
one of my roommates in the house, he
went down wanting to just see snakes and,
and other things you'd heard about. And
I think the Iowasca knew that. And, uh,
the entire time he was down there,
he didn't see one vision and I mean,
he would take his shirt off,
he'd be like, okay, let's go.
The Shama would bring in his strongest
brew serving three cups and still
nothing.
Maybe the guy was a robot,
but I'm so you just never know. You
never know what you're going to get. But,
but I do believe it
would benefit everybody.
I'm sorry. They, they say that about DMT.
That it's like one out of every 20
people experiences nothing. Wow.
You smoking and everybody else gets blown
through. The center of the Universe is,
sees complex patterns made out of
love and understanding that, you know,
see through your soul,
but they don't experience anything.
It was like one out of 20 people,
they either have zero effect.
Maybe that's what happened to him.
I felt so bad because they made the trip
down to the jungle and was like a tool
for the universe. Brought them out.
The university is like, listen,
we're not going to give you any
reason. Yeah. I don't know the guy.
Maybe the guy was rude. Cool.
Oh yeah. He's super amazing,
but it just sucked the,
you know,
he didn't get to see anything.
But that's kind of the medicine saying
you need, you need to have an intent.
It's like it goes back to set and setting.
You need to have that mindset of wanting
healing and wanting to accept the
medicine. Or like you said,
Joe, things can go ah,
pretty wrong.
I wonder if there's like a pharmacological
reason there a biological reason why
some people don't. Maybe
they'd have a, there's,
they're missing some sort of expression
of a gene or some point that it doesn't
allow them to have the experience
or potential and we maybe the
calcification of pineal glands.
I don't know if that affects it,
but that just has been something
I've been reading about.
The water tends to cause
that and other things.
So real though, I mean how much
real work has been done on that.
The problem is you go to these websites,
then you read, you know, big foot,
read my mind.
They put,
read your mind and the calcification,
the pineal gland, for the longest time,
it was a massive source
of debate. In fact, um,
the debate about whether or not the
pineal gland actually even had DMT in it.
And Rick Strassman, who's a friend of
mine and a really, really interesting,
cool guy who wrote the spirit
molecule Dmt, the spirit molecule. Uh,
he did all those studies at
University of New Mexico and, uh,
they had only anecdotal evidence that
it was produced by the pineal gland.
I knew it was produced by the liver
and the lungs, but the actual,
the third eye at eastern mysticism,
the pineal gland,
which in certain reptiles actually
has a retina in a lens in,
it's actually an eyeball and
certain reptiles, it's spring.
It's really fucking crazy that this gland,
like the third eye,
it's like there's a reason why it exists
in all these ancient depictions of
enlightenment. And that is literally worth
DMT is processed. It's where it's made.
And so recently, just really recently, uh,
Strassman's cottonwood research center,
they figured out that they
could observe it in live rats.
So now they know for a fact that the
pineal gland in live rats produces DMT.
So it's very, very, very likely that the
same thing is going on with human beings.
And what, what happened to you
when you smoked DMT? I haven't,
I've mostly stuck to Iowasca
and mushrooms, so that's
what I've been researching.
But what happens when you,
when you smoke it?
Well, um, I've,
I've smoked a couple of different
types to have smoked five methoxy DMT,
which is a quite different,
the experience is much more of a,
there's like DMT seems to allow you to
keep who you are and DMT allows you to
examine the culture from some sort of a
new realm that it doesn't take you away
from the very world that you live in.
It just shows you another one.
It brings you, it would take
you and put you in this place.
It doesn't change who you are though,
which is really interesting.
Like when you're drunk, it changes
who you are, you know, you, you,
you're more loose and you
know, maybe a little more
rowdy. It say silly, your shit,
whatever it is that your
particular reaction is. But
your thinking has changed.
Your, your thinking has changed
when you're on, you know, opiates,
your thinking has changed when you're
on marijuana, not when you're on DMT.
You're thinking exactly the same,
but all of a sudden this
door opens in your mind.
You step like on like on your, on how
you step out onto the elevator. You know,
you make that, that step over
that gap. You see the floor,
you see the elevator and the doors open
as the doors of the elevators rising up.
So,
and you look down,
you're forced to look down and there's
this little slice of air between that
elevator in the hotel and then he realized
what the fuck you're really doing.
You really stepping into this box that's
hovering 70 80 fucking stories over the
ground held up by steel cables and you're
going to go ride in this box and the
door shuts. And that's what DMT
feels like. DMT feels like ready?
Come on in. You too. Don't
you step over this chasms,
that door shots and then it opens
and then you just fucking go.
It's like getting shot through
a cannon of geometric patterns.
And what I remember is the beginning of
it literally being like the beginning of
a ride.
Like it's slowly exposed itself.
Initially you have blinders on and it's,
it's colored like a yellow jacket,
be like yellow and black. That's what
I remember. Like intensely strong,
a yellow and black that's moving like
sort of spiraling but it's square and
it's,
it's very square and it's essentially
like giving you like a little bit of a,
a slow fucking before it goes
after you. It's like here, come on,
just going to give you a little kiss and
ma, it's like massaging your shoulders,
like shooting you down this pipe,
this crazy squared off pipe and
then boom into the big thing.
And the beginning of it
was so like Holy Shit.
Like what am I looking at that you think
their kitten be anything stranger in
the world until it lets you
out of the bottom until boom.
And you think that's as crazy as it gets.
And then as you go deeper in,
it shows you something crazier and
it shows you that there's no end.
And it also connects you to
such overwhelming evidence
of things being far more
fantastic than you could ever be aware.
Just overwhelming evidence.
Just the fact that you could personally
with your eyes ever experience what
you're seeing, that it could be
possible. Even if it's a hallucination,
it is still happening.
You're still seeing this and this
very experience should be impossible.
It's too alien.
It's too beyond the imaginations to
beyond anything I've could have concocted
based on the context of the life
that I've lived. It's impossible.
And then they started singing,
I love you six months and 500,000 times
look at this. And they would say like,
look at this and show you these fucking
things that were impossibly beautiful.
Like I remember crying because there
were the things they were showing me were
so beautiful and they kept saying like a,
like a little child.
The way a child would tell you they
love you. Like I love you 600 million,
500,000 times, look at
this. And just, but that,
that childish love to it,
like was a big theme of it.
This, this repeating that I love
you 600 million, 500,000 times.
Like if you tell a kid they love you,
they go, I love you a hundred times.
And he's like, I love you a million times.
I love you. 6 million, 500,000 times.
They would say something crazy like that.
And that's what this thing was, was,
was saying and then just showing. And
I know even you think it was 6 million,
500,000 times,
that's like my interpretation of it.
Cause you're not here in real words or
you're just getting like this really
clear intent that seems
to be talking to you,
but you don't know how it's
talking to you. You're not,
it's not like you seen it like on a wall,
like in you reading it and it's somehow
or another putting those words in your
head. So I'm saying 6
million, 500,000 times,
but it was really just that sort of
an interpretation of like a childish,
you know, pure love. They're not
trying to be your girlfriend,
they're not trying to, you know, get a
job. They're not trying to, you know,
get you to give them money.
They're just, this is pure love,
pure love without any context at all.
And just a series of beautiful,
fantastic visions that
you're trying to grab,
you try to hold onto,
but you can't.
The way I describe it as like standing
in the middle of a river of fish that are
going a thousand miles an hour and you
just try to grab them and there's no way,
there's no way in, but you recognize
what you're seeing when you're seeing it,
but you can't even hold onto it
because there are new ones common.
And a new one is so much more crazy than
the one you just saw. And then boom,
a new ones there and their infinite,
and they never end.
And they keep going until the drug
wears off. And as the drug wears off,
there was, you know, like the
love you thing was still going on,
but there was also like a lot of,
we'll see
you later.
There's like a like a
bye bye bye bye.
Like letting you know they, they
had a good time and then, you know,
we'll see you some other time when
you're ready. We're here. Wow.
Wow. How do you go back to reality
after? How do you get a fear factor?
The first I'm like, what
am I doing here? Holy
Schnitzel. This is a,
it was the first one.
The first one I did was the
five methoxy one and five.
Methoxy is much more um,
reality dissolving.
It's like you don't see anything.
You just, you don't exist anymore.
You as you, you're not allowed to keep,
you know, you keep it with DMT. You don't,
you as you,
you don't keep with five meo.
You as you goes away and you
enter to the center of everything,
he become a part of the
very fiber of the universe.
You look at the universe
from a different perspective,
the perspective that you're at right
now as a multi-celled organism host to
millions and billions in fact of other
multicell organisms. And you're, you know,
you're just getting through life,
getting in your car, driving around.
You look at it through the
energy of the cell itself,
like you look at it through the,
the momentum of biological
life and evolution.
You look at it through a completely
non society based concept,
through completely contacts rather
through a completely alien context like
you're seeing the world through,
not through the eyes of a mammal,
not through the eyes of a fish,
not through the eyes of life,
not through the eyes of
anything with biology,
not through the eyes of anything that
has any instincts to stay alive to the
eyes of something that realizes it's a
part of everything and that there's no
bottom, there's no up, there's
all and it's all around you
all the time. And I was,
the first time I really came
to understand the idea of um,
standing on something as ridiculous,
like the idea that like I'm on the ground,
like we're standing here in my office.
It's so ridiculous because we're not,
we're spinning a thousand
miles an hour in a circle.
That circle is a part of a greater
system called the solar system.
That system is a part of a
greater system called the galaxy.
The whole thing is spinning
around a black hole.
Like we're not fee does nothing
flat. It's up, it's down, it's left,
it's right.
And in having that experience experience,
I felt like I was somehow
or another just in there,
a part of the mechanism of the very
universe itself. But it was very not me.
And then when I had a comeback, I had to
sort of re put together my personality.
We put together my position in the world
as far as like what my responsibilities
are, what is expected of me or what I'm
supposed to be doing on Monday morning.
I had to re put that all together cause
I didn't exist for 15, 20 minutes,
whatever it was, probably
15. Um, and then, um,
sort of examine how preposterous I am now.
Examine ego exam.
I remember him just saying to my friends
after we had just got done doing it.
Like I can't even even me describing
this to you is bullshit because what I'm
trying to do is sound clever in
the way I'm choosing my words.
I'm allowing my ego to paint. Uh, um,
I want you to be entertained by my words.
I don't just want these words to come
out absolutely perfectly truthful forum.
I'm also trying to, I'm trying to
be clever. I like to use words.
I like to sing a song with words,
you know,
and I'm realizing that as I'm saying this,
that it's like I'm full of Shit.
We're all like, yes, there's a benefit to
being full of shit. The benefit is like,
like, um, it's not even full of shit.
It's just like my friend Joey
Diaz is my favorite human ever.
Like the way he talks.
I love being around him.
He's just so much fun and
it's the way he talks.
He knows that people
love the way he talks.
So he's really good at singing a song
with his words, you know, and to,
to get to get off that,
to try to look at something
out off that trip.
The trip of singing a song with your
words is really hard and DMT makes that
song look stupid as fuck because DMT
lets you know, like, I get it, I get it.
You think that in the context of
humanity and civilization and your
interpersonal relationships that you
have with other beings to what you're
saying is important, but it's not. And
here's, here's evidence that it's not,
here's evidence that nothing is important
and whatever you do that makes this
time,
this thing that you think is important,
whatever you do that makes that
fucked up, stop, stop all that,
stop all that craziness. Whatever
you're doing, it's causing you anxiety.
Whatever you're doing that's causing you
too much a objective, thinking too much,
uh, you know, interact,
interviewing yourself and going
over the thoughts and like,
why am I doing that? Why am
I still smoking? Why am I,
why am I still eating shitty food?
Why don't we just stop doing all that?
Because that's a mess. That's a mess. You
don't need that. It just made you look,
it made me look so foolish,
but it's very different than nn DMT.
Just so those are the two experiences
that I had, that I had both of them.
I only did the five meo three times,
but the regular DMT was about five or
six more because it was just the regular
DMT was more, um, more
interesting to me. I figured like,
I felt like whatever the five meo had
to say, I got it. I got a pretty quick,
not that I couldn't benefit from a or B,
but didn't, didn't call me back. You know,
it was like, there it is, bitch,
take a look. You got it. Good.
Now go about your business.
Whereas DMT was, um,
every time was a new thing. Every time
I did it, it was a new, it was similar,
but every time was like, oh, I
think I know what this is about. Oh,
do you really come through here,
sir? Here we go. You Ready?
Woo.
And then some new thing that
you're like, Oh, fucking Christ.
That's how the IOWASCA is. I, uh,
one of the healers I work with has been
using it for 18 years and he says still,
every time he does it, it's different
and it completely opens his mind to,
he still can't figure it out. And
it's been, it's been 18 years. And uh,
and I think something else Iowasca is
good for when you look at through a
therapeutic or medical scope,
which is kinda similar to what
you had in your DMT experience,
is that it does take away a lot of the
fear of life and the fear of dying.
And I think that's something to that
that I had and most people do have a fear
of death. And, um, one time I, uh,
had IOWASCA and I hadn't
eaten in five days,
so I was really ready
to absorb the medicine.
And right after drinking it, Joe,
I started feeling like I was dying.
And I started thinking,
oh my gosh,
has anyone died from Iowasca because
I just in my brain it was telling me,
you're,
you're dying.
And I started having trouble breathing
and I was remembering that if I didn't
remember to breathe,
I couldn't breathe.
And then it got the
feeling got so intense, um,
that I remember looking over at my
boyfriend and thinking how sad it was that
I'd never see him again. At that point,
I started seeing sacred geometry.
And then I,
I literally left my body and became this
vibration and I looked back in my body
thinking it's so sad I couldn't
hold on to that body. You know,
what's wrong with me that everyone in
this room is able to stay alive and I had
to die.
So how many trips have you got
on before this had happened?
Um, that was my eighth
one. So at this point,
just fuck the eighth visit or eighth,
eighth time drinking.
Iowasca so during the first visit,
um, no, this was a separate time.
So I had a,
I went down to the Amazon,
then I've traveled the world the past
year researching mushrooms. And then, um,
when I was in Indonesia,
I was given the opportunity to be
included in an Iowaska experience.
This was a couple of months ago
and this is when this happened.
I wanted to ask you that. The, um,
I've talked to people that
have done Iowasca with, um,
things that have come from the
Middle East, different plants,
and we come from the Middle East.
They,
they've mixed it and they've seen very
different imagery than the imagery that
people report saying from the
jungles of Peru and Brazil.
Apparently what they're Mckenna's idea
was that it might've been someone else's
idea that he had talked
about in his speech. He, uh,
believed that when you had
a psychedelic experience,
you were also participating in all the
various trips that everyone else had
done. Would that psychedelic like
essentially throughout history.
And that was one of the reasons why
fairly recent drugs had an empty feeling.
Like he would talk about ketamine and he
said that ketamine would feel like you
were in an office building that was new,
but nobody had moved into yet.
And like there'd be no one there
and it'd be like walking around,
there's no furniture. Like
this is bizarre. He's like,
that was the experience that he had had
with ketamine. Whereas with Psilocybin,
he would have these experiences that
were just intensely rich with all this
sacred imagery that has been,
you know,
observed and artwork and at
various cultures like the,
they have like this interchangeable
imagery that may have like very similar
psychedelic consumptions. And that,
that's what you're seeing when, you know,
when you're seeing Jaguars
and black people and snakes,
when you do the Iowasca and where you
do the Iowasca from the South American
Iowasca.
But when you would do the Iowasca that
was made with similar ingredients on the
other parts of the world,
you have different visions.
Oh, for sure. And this one,
I mean the ones I had in the
jungle where like you said,
more jungle ask and this
one, uh, was brewed, uh,
in an area of Australia.
And so for some reason it was just a
completely different experience for me.
And it could have also been,
there could've been other variables that
I didn't need as much personal healing.
Instead, I was led to this knowledge.
Sometimes Iowasca is more of a,
uh, a ladder to bring you to this higher
intelligence to feed you knowledge.
And um,
and so I wasn't having any animalistic
visions or are really sacred geometry.
I just became, flew out of my
body and became this vibration.
And it told me clearly,
like you said,
I don't know if it was a a
voice or writing or what,
but this huge intense power
told me that that doesn't exist.
And why do we fear death? Why does
man fear death? It's ridiculous.
And it's just to cause fear.
And really you are this vibration,
this soul and amber,
your body on earth is just your
organic space suit that allows you to,
to survive on earth, but you really
are, are the sole and no matter what,
you never really die. And it was
laughing like it how ridiculous that is.
That man thinks,
peep you actually die.
And then I was just taken through the
universe and I just was flying down this
four techs and I saw earth and I saw
all the fighting and wars and all the
negativity that I'd focused
on for all these years.
And I saw how petty that
was compared to this huge,
massive force that was
communicating with me. Um,
whether it be God or
intelligent beings or,
or just something made up in my head,
but it was just so intense.
Um, and I compared that to all
the fighting and the negativity,
and it just left a permanent footprint
on my brain that I need to, you know,
whatever.
This force,
this message is so much more important
than what I've been focusing on, uh,
on earth, especially in my career. And,
and it started giving me this message of,
of love and healing and,
and that we really need to get
in and fix the core problem,
which is a,
this mental disorder facing our species,
uh, versus just focusing on the
symptoms for me journalistically,
which was wars and fighting. And then, um,
after that I was shown how man was created
according to this. Oh, please do tell.
Um, it just was, I was shown DNA and
I was showing that it was a DNA, um,
mixing and I had not read any
theories or anything else on this,
but I was shown DNA taken from other
areas of the universe mixed with DNA on
earth. And then that's how man
was created as part of, yeah,
it was pretty intense. Um,
as part of this plan. Um,
and uh, I don't know.
That's a good question. I,
I couldn't tell exactly
what this force was, but um,
but that's what it was showing.
How many we have this idea like,
oh please,
you're saying that aliens made people
and came down with different DNA,
but just life itself on
this planet is so strange.
It's so bizarre. It's all of it.
All of it. Everything from mines,
eating gazelles to the whole air.
Everything we do is so strange
and bizarre. Color's changing.
I animals a Chameleon's change there.
The color of their skin to try to blend
in like octopus do that and the ocean
floor,
so much of it is so incredibly strange.
The idea that we haven't been influenced
at some of this has not been influenced
by similar strangeness from
somewhere else. It's so silly.
The idea that pollen and then spores
and the things fly through the air and
seeds land and that new life
comes out of those seeds.
The idea that that's on a universal
idea, you know, the idea that, you know,
asteroids don't carry the building
blocks of, of life. Well they do. They,
we know they do. So they do.
Isn't that sort of an a spaceship.
I mean it isn't an asteroid,
a spaceship,
but spaceship that carry something from
like if some Dna from something came
here on an asteroid and collided with
something else and then created a person.
Why is that so weird?
Why is it so weird for us?
And, and that's what this forest was
showing me. And I'd never really,
I never thought about this.
I wasn't very religious person.
I am more now definitely your religious,
no, not religious, but I believe in a,
in a higher being, right? That
something is, there's more to,
to our time on earth. And I used to
just think that you die, you die. And,
and now I'm a,
it's a recurring theme for me when I do
use psychedelics to remind me that life
does not end, uh, on
earth. Maybe amber ends,
but the real being me,
my soul will continue on.
And then that's just been
a recurring theme even,
especially on the mushrooms. Um,
they constantly try to tell me that
lesson because I think a lot of my anxiety
came from a fear of death.
Well, it's kind of weird because
we, in order to do what we do,
in order to be a person, in order to
have a job, in order to, you know,
write your name down when you
signed the Amber Lyon, this is my,
this is what represents me. You
have to have a pilot. You know,
it has to be amber in there,
run the show.
And so because of that amber run,
the show becomes amber.
But when you have a
psychedelic experience,
amber run the show really
doesn't get a chance to say shit.
And then this other thing
gets revealed at the core.
You know, without a language, it doesn't
have a language. It doesn't have,
it's not clinging to life experiences.
It's not clean to, um, you know,
phobias that you've developed
because of negative experiences,
not cleaning anything. It's just as
pure consciousness. That's very, very,
very hard to access. That's the real
silence. That's the, the real silence.
At the end of meditation,
there's the real you,
which you're very rarely even get to see.
And it's very, very spiritual. Uh, if
you look at the John Hopkins Studies,
they found that 61% of people who were
given silicide been considered it to be
the single most spiritual
event of their life. Um,
also you even look at a Bill Wilson
who founded alcoholics anonymous.
He believed that a lot of
people don't know this,
but he used Lsd to cure
chronic depression.
He believed the LSD could actually,
um,
should be one of the 12 steps and could
lead people to that spiritual awakening,
which would then allow them to acknowledge
a greater power and continue in their
healing. Don't tell that to
doctor drew. And it's so sad show.
Cause as the more I've
been researching this,
the more I realize how much
amazing research is out
there showing how effective
psychedelics are for curing anxiety,
depression and addiction.
All of these things so many
people are suffering from.
And we've known since the 1950s,
the LSD had a 45% rate
it curing alcoholism.
I mean if you look at Aa,
there's a study showing there are not
even any studies to show how effective LSD
is. Some people say it's or
a a is in curing alcoholism.
Some people say it's maybe 5% effective.
So you have these substances
out there that are uh,
we've known for decades now.
We're extremely healing. Yeah.
It is really effective at
getting people to talk about Aa.
Exactly. I suppose I thought
you folks were anonymous.
They bring that shit up constantly.
You don't think God damn,
I mean I'm sure some people are helped,
but there are definitely 45% success
rate with LSD is really an astounding
number when it comes to rehab and,
and we need to start talking
about psychedelics more.
We need to make them less taboo so people
start realizing that there is hope out
there when they've lost all of hope.
Okay.
Ibogaine is actually even
stronger than that as far as,
uh, the numbers, uh, the, uh,
the Ibogaine recidivism rate as far as
people going back to whatever they were
doing, it was fucking them up is
incredibly low, incredibly low.
And especially with the
Oxi content addiction,
which is just consuming our nation.
I think one of my last stories I did
at CNN are on babies now being born
addicted to Oxycontin and painkillers,
which was really my holy shit.
What has happened to
us as a society moment?
And you have sick like
right out of the bat. Yeah.
They're going through withdrawal once
they're born because the mom can't quit
using the oxycodone while she's pregnant
because the baby could die in utero
from withdrawal. So she's got to
continue using it. Then these babies,
I was standing in a Nicu it east
Tennessee children's hospital in a Nicu.
They've literally,
half the babies there are being
born addicted to these painkillers.
This is something our
society is not discussing.
And I watched as they brought this
baby in and this poor baby was, um,
it's skin was marbled and it was just
shaking and screaming and crying and
intense pain just like a grownup would
because this baby was going through,
uh,
opioid withdrawal and they
had to instantly give the
baby morphine and it takes
sometimes 30 days for them to
overcome the painful symptoms.
We had a, a, a doctor and Dr.
Carl Hart yesterday who, uh, is a,
a drug and addictions expert.
The guys worked for over
20 years on various,
uh, tests and various substance
and abuse substances and,
and analyzing what the root
of all these experiences are.
And the way he explained
it was really fascinating.
He was saying that even when you
have a hangover, the hangover is,
is an alcohol withdrawal. That's what
you're, that you're going through.
It's not just a dehydration, not
just your body, like being sick.
It's the compensatory mechanisms that are
present in your mind to counteract the
alcohol when the alcohol is
gone, it's, or withdrawal.
Like you go into like
that's what a hangover is.
And that whenever
someone has an addiction,
whether it's an addiction to
opiates or with whatever it is,
that's what they're experiencing.
It's the compensatory mechanisms fire
up in order to process the opiates.
And then when they're gone,
then you're sick and you know,
but the way he was describing
it was really fascinating.
He was saying that it's really like,
I'm sure it's way worse for
a fucking baby obviously,
but for a person it's essentially
like having a bad flu.
And then if you've gone through
the flu, you've gone through, uh,
what would it feels like to
have a withdrawal heroin,
which I thought was really fascinating.
It's like a lot of it is misconceptions,
misconceptions and um,
disinformation when it comes to what
withdrawals from drugs and how difficult
they are to withdraw from. And a lot of
it is psychosomatic. There's a lot of, uh,
uh,
psychological issues in involved with
people relapse saying that don't have
anything to do with chemical.
Pretty interesting stuff.
And I think that's why
Ibogaine so effective.
I think some people think it's maybe
around 90% affective success rate because
they don't experience withdrawal symptoms.
I think that's why so many people
are scared or addicts I've spoken to,
especially who are addicted to these
prescription pills as they're so scared to
go through those withdraw
symptoms. And, um, what,
even the young man who
discovered Ibogaine,
he actually went to try it because
he thought he could get stoned.
So he was just looking for a high and
he was a heroin addict and he tried the
Ibogaine and then all of a sudden he
realized, oh my gosh, it's been 12 hours.
I should be having horrific
withdrawal symptoms.
Why am I not experiencing these symptoms?
And then it was so effective, uh,
toward the end of the trip, after intense
introspection, I mean, intense. You're,
you're in that trip for
about 36 hours for some, uh,
he realized he no longer crave the heroin.
So then he went and got all of his other
junky friends and started giving them
Ibogaine,
and then it just spread across the world.
Now we're seeing centers open up in Mexico
and unfortunately it's still illegal
in the United States, even though
we have a horrific pill addiction.
But you can access a Ibogaine
centers in Canada and in Mexico,
even The Bahamas.
That's intense. I have a friend who
had an addiction to pills, went down,
did Obgyn, cured him completely, and
then he opened up a center. Wow. Yeah.
He's like, this is
incredible. It's unbelievable.
So now he's got a center
in Mexico and you know,
he was a guy that was like
a really healthy guy and
then he got injured and then
the pills just took him over.
He could,
he just couldn't help it and he had a
really hard time getting rid of him,
you know, for whatever reason. But
when he went there, boom, it's instant,
instant, instant cure, instant like
never doing that again. Holy Shit.
Instant like recognition of the patterns
and then an instant calling to to,
to be involved in this and to help other
people and to find friends that he knew
that had similar issues and say, listen,
you got to trust me on this. Come with me.
Once you've seen the truth
that how powerful psychedelics
are and you're able to
dispel all the propaganda with this truth
that doesn't have a shelf life that's
going come out. Just like
you know, now marijuana,
everyone's finally really
realizing how medicinal it is now.
It's just starting to happen
again with psychedelics.
And when you've personally
realize this truth,
and this is something I'm going through
now and you see so many people around
the country suffering,
whether it be from a depression anxiety
or from post traumatic stress disorder,
22 soldiers a day in the United
States killed themselves from it.
You just feel a duty like you have
to share this truth with others and,
and let people know through your
experiences because they are so powerful.
Yeah, it is unbelievably
powerful and just, it's just,
it's sort of like one of the things
that we were talking about earlier that
we're, we are in some sort
of a new era. It's that this,
the information is being spread
virally on things like this.
These discussions are happening right
now during lunchtime at schools, during
coffee breaks,
at work.
People are talking about these sort of
things that they're realizing and they're
there talking about things that they
heard talk about things that they've read
or videos they've
watched or what have you,
and it's spreading now and it's spreading
in a way that just really never did
before
and, and they can't hold it back.
You can't hold back the truth. And,
and these psychedelics,
they're not, they're not going
to work for everybody. But,
but if you look at the
anecdotes and the science,
it's really there and in favor of,
of using these medicinally and it,
the more research you read,
the more ridiculous it becomes
that they're scheduled.
One saying that there's no
med to snow value, that, that
they're highly addictive.
Mushrooms are proven to be non addictive
and the caffeine in your coffee is more
toxic for your body.
Then mushrooms,
the deadliest drug on earth is alcohol
and that's legal. And the more,
so the more information you have
access to. Um, as for me personally,
because I'm just waking up to all of
this, um, within the past year or so, uh,
the more you realize just how ridiculous
the whole system is and it's just not
in the favor of healing and the people,
yeah.
Most people don't realize way more
people die from alcohol then do from even
prescription drugs.
Yeah. 80,000 a year. That's
more than car accidents.
More than a hundred. It's still not as
bad as cigarettes. Yeah. Number one.
And that one isn't even get your hot,
what guests?
It does get you high a little bit.
It gives you like a little of a,
of a psychoactive charge. It gives you a
little, like a little stimulant charge.
A lot of people like it
for writing apparently.
Apparently you'd smoked cigarettes and
bright like your synapses fire really.
Well Stephen King actually said that
when he quit smoking. Effected that.
Yeah, I used to smoke
occasionally when I'd right.
Does the IOWASCA era, when he's
blowing the tobacco smoke on you,
what is the role that
the nicotine and tobacco,
the tobacco smoke has on the IOWASCA trip?
Uh,
for me it just in intensifies it.
Sometimes they blow like a sage smoke
or Palo Santo Wood and that intensifies
you feeling nauseous
and, and the trip, um,
others say that they use it to clear out
the bad spirits and blow them away so
that bad spirits don't come into the room.
They also use this a wand called Chicago
Chicago and it's like a leaf want to
blow the spirits out of the room
so that bad spirits don't come in.
That is one of the really blowing out
bad spirits or they just tricking you,
you know, like the tricking your mind to
think it's blowing out with bad spirits.
So it eliminates the fear.
Yeah. Well it depends on
the showman you're getting.
It's so vital that you pick
the right Shawmut you've
got to go back to that then.
Yeah, the showman touched you. Yeah.
So I went down and
unfortunately now there's a new
organizations are starting to
really help rate Iowasca centers and give,
and this is why I'm starting the website
I'm starting as well because there's
not a lot out there when it comes to
advising you where to go as far as picking
a center.
I think now there's a new site called
[inaudible] advisor.org like TripAdvisor.
So I didn't know. Um, so I went
down to this center and, um,
I didn't know that the
Shaman who I had gone to, um,
had other accusations against him.
Um, and so during the ceremony,
while I was deepen this really spiritual,
amazing trip,
um, I noticed him coming up to me
and blowing the Agua Florida Ami,
which is normal. It's the, like the holy
water for the [inaudible]. And he was,
you know, putting,
putting it on my forehead.
And then he started putting his hands
down my body and actually went around my
breasts and went down towards,
um, towards my crotch. Whoa.
And then kept just rubbing back and
forth and, and I thought that, okay,
maybe is that part of
healing the bad spirits?
Rub your actual breasts or round
your breasts? He rubbed like it was,
he was clearly touching. I mean, he,
he made it try to seem like he
was going around the outside,
but he was clearly pushing down on, on
my breast to the point I'm in the middle,
taking the most intense psychedelic on
north. And I kind of was like, Whoa,
hold on a minute.
And then the mother Iowasca I need to
take care of something in this dimension
because something ain't right.
And um, and he also went to, uh,
the, the guy who was next to me and
rubbed him in the crotch area as well.
How dare he, maybe that's a
part of it though. Maybe they
have to rub your deck. I,
I've talked to every Shawman I've
talked to after that said no.
And actually when he found out I was a
journalist, he fled, um, the next day he,
and came up with some outlandish excuse
of why he needed be gone until the exact
day I left. And, um,
and I think he thought maybe I was there
to investigate other accusations that
had been made against him and he left.
And then we had the local Sharman, uh,
who was native to Peru,
uh,
give us a ceremonies after that and it
was all beautiful from there and he never
touched or anything like that.
And,
and it's not part of the IOWASCA
experience to have your breasts touch or,
or anything else on your body,
just so people know.
And that's why it's so vital that you
pick the correct Sharman because they're
guiding you through this experience.
And that's also why I don't people, um,
women go down alone at this time
point. Yeah. Wow. That's in terms, well,
luckily that's all it happened. Nothing
escalated from there.
But do you know if that car is still
well? Um, unfortunately he
passed away unfortunately.
Well, either way, whatever happened.
It's weird because people tend to say
that the spirits of the jungle kind of
take care of anything that comes in and
tries to use the medicine the wrong way.
And oddly enough,
he died around Christmas time.
He fell off the third floor of,
of his home.
He'd built in the jungle and hit his head
and passed away. And when I heard that,
because I had heard other
stories of Charmaine's who've
misused the medicine and
they've kind of had weird fates
as well. Um, you know, I wasn't,
I wouldn't be surprised at
the spirits kind of just,
and some dude who's Dicky grab
threw him off the fucking one.
Yeah.
You never know.
But that's the sad thing
with the medicines is there
some of the most profound
compounds on earth for healing.
But I think something I've noticed
too in traveling the world, Joe,
is that some people have taken advantage
of them and claimed to be healers.
And really in the end of the day,
the only healer,
the main healer is the actual psychedelic.
All you need to do is take
that psychedelic go be
with yourself and it and it
will do the healing.
You don't need a healer per se,
and you just have to be very cautious
because people coming in with the wrong
intentions maybe just to make money,
have our opening up centers and
yeah,
I've talked to quite a few people that
claim to be a healer and I just think
that the idea is so
preposterous. A, it's the,
it's a very preposterous idea that
someone was gifted with these magic powers
and be thinking that you are is
so fucking delusional that it,
it is absolutely contrary to the spirit
of psychedelic exploration in the first
place. Thinking you're the one person
that has this unique gift and you can heal
people. Get the fuck out of here. Stop.
I knew this dude who was a chiropractor,
used to crack people's backs and tell
them that your heel and foot fungus,
he's making you smarter. He's fixing
your zones and like, what are you doing?
You're healing. And then in a, in
a sort of a discrete conversation,
he revealed to me that if he
convinces people that they're healing,
that that does in fact start the
healing. And I'm like, okay, what?
So you're justifying bullshitting
by saying that the bullshit works.
If the people believe it, it's
like a placebo effect. Your B,
you're a human placebo effect. Well it
didn't work with me dude. Okay. At all.
Like this is a really bad
conversation we're having.
It sounds like you're a bullshit or
like this is ridiculous. Like this.
The idea behind it is ridiculous that one
person would have some sort of magical
power with their hands to heal things
like get the fuck outta here, man. Stop.
The power is in the psychedelic medicine
and the most amazing healer I met along
the way was this man in Wahaca Mexico.
I went there to investigate how the mass
attacks have been using medicinally for
thousands of years cause it's kind of
contradicts everything we've been told
about magic mushrooms that they're
actually a medicine there. And um,
and the healer actually what he would do,
we just bring people in.
He would make the t give you the mushrooms
and then say, okay, here's my property.
Go sit wherever you want and be one with
the mushrooms and the mushrooms will do
the healing. I'm not a
healer, I'm just a provider.
And to me that was so profound because
we had run into on this journey so many
phoneys who wanted $400
for a ceremony or you know,
they, they're hands are the hands of
God with, with these psychedelics.
And it really is just the medicine. That's
all. That's all you need. You don't,
you don't need someone else to bring you.
Well it seems like in [inaudible] and it
become more and more becoming more and
more popular over the last few years.
The demand for it is so hard.
There's gotta be a lot of unscrupulous
people that are sort of capitalizing on
that demand and people who never wore a
Sharman. So just figure out the recipe,
cook it up, start serving
people and squeeze and tits and
like this is the best job ever
touching their dicks. Awesome.
Give me 200 bucks a night,
which is like a monthly
salary in my country. Yeah,
sense it seems like they need like an
accreditation thing, like sort of like,
you know, where'd you get your phd at
Columbia? Oh, that guy's legit. You know,
where, where did you get your Iowasca
Kero a license to practice what
it does exist.
But I mean,
almost more important than being a
phd. I mean, did the ability to, to,
to accurately describe what happens in
those dimensions to someone who hasn't
experienced it is impossible.
The,
the idea behind what you're experiencing
is so fantastic that any words to
describe it are going to fall
short. So the guy who could
administer that, uh, the,
the function of that person and your
society and your culture is uniquely
important and in a really intense way.
Just as important as
someone who's a doctor.
someone who's a teacher.
Just as important as any important aspect
of our community that we consider to
be a cornerstone, whether it's medical
or legal or any of those things.
Like having someone who can give
you that experience is a huge,
that's a huge role.
But you know who's doing it?
He's a fucking weird guys that are
touching you while you're passed out.
Not all of them are bad.
There's some really amazing horse.
I had lost faith almost Joe.
And then I met some incredible,
a real ios Keros and [inaudible]
scare a woman who, um,
who's been doing it for years and they
were so profoundly helped me heal and
understand the medicine that,
that there is a lot of good,
but it's a yin and Yang. And, and that's
why just warn people because I think,
oh well this, she went down there
alone and the jungle and it's like, no,
it wasn't all rainbows and
butterflies. Like I had some, uh,
some things to have to
overcome there because I,
I did chose to kind of
go down there so quick.
Well,
I think it's like everything in life.
There's going to be good versions of and
bad versions of it and we should seek
to find the ideal version of it. You
know? And I think also the this, the,
that Yin and Yang balance of
the universe seems inescapable.
It seems like it's in everything,
like really terrible relationships.
They make you appreciate
really good relationships.
Bad friends make you appreciate, good
friends, bad jobs make you appreciate,
good jobs. Traffic makes you appreciate
the mountains even more. I mean,
all those things factor in together.
I don't think there,
I don't think that you can escape them.
I think you need them all.
You need the Yin and the Yang.
You need the Shitty Ios Garrow to make
you really appreciate the beauty of
someone who's absolutely
pure and their intent.
I really think that this is the
way the world works. You know?
I think you tried to get away from that.
You're being silly.
You're missing the whole point.
The whole point is just seek the light,
go towards the good.
Just find that he can't fix all the dark.
It's not fixable like either
the people involved in the dark.
You have to recognize they're leaning
one way more than they are the other and
try to correct.
Hopefully somehow or another they're
going to have an experience that comes,
that gives them that sort
of understanding. But you're
not going to fix them,
concentrate on your own shit,
move forward, go, go, go,
go, seek the light, you know,
go, go the right way. And for some
folks, they just never quite get there.
And I don't know what their role is,
but their role may very well be for
someone like you or someone like me to see
the error of their ways and learn from it.
And that might be their
place in this giant machine.
Their place might truly be to enlighten
the others around them as to the wrong
way.
And maybe when they come back,
they'll come back with the knowledge of
whatever they fucked up in the past life
and some sort of inherent form,
and they'll move incrementally closer
and closer to some form of enlightenment.
And, and it really helped me
journalistically because I'm,
I'm not only trying to use
the psychedelics for healing,
but also to really understand the
history. And, uh, and for some reason,
after that first experience,
I just had my bullshit
meter on right times 4,000.
So right away I could weed through the
bullshit and just get to the healers who
could teach me the most journalistically,
especially when I was traveling
through Mexico. Cause that,
I mean already it's some areas
of there are a little sketchy.
And so it really helped me to find
the real native Corrine Darras and,
and have just an amazing, beautiful
experience with these mushrooms that, um,
I have such a profound love for mushrooms.
Uh,
now Joe and I understand
why when I was on your show,
you were saying that if everyone could
do mushrooms that would just transform
the world.
And I'm a firm believer psilocybin is
hands down the most incredible chemical
known to the brain.
And just through my experiences,
well, it's really close to human
neuro chemistry too. I mean,
it literally has a n n
dimethyltryptamine in it.
As far as like what it is before
it is that it's, um, there's, it's,
it's very closely related.
Um,
and the most profound ones are closely
related to human, neuro chemistry. I mean,
the idea that you're going to get this
DMT trip from all these plants that grow
in the jungle there, these plants are
grown in a jungle, literally contain the,
the very chemicals that make your
brain work. It's so, so busy.
They're illegal and they really go,
yeah,
ignore everything you've been told
about them. It's all, it's all lies.
When I first had my first mushroom
experience, I really realized, wow,
how deep the propaganda
went. And, um, and we,
we've just been fed so many lies about,
about these substances,
especially silicide, but I feel like, uh,
the industry has a lot of
fear of psilocybin because
it can't be patented and it
is so effective. One study at the
University of Southern Florida,
uh, found out, uh,
scientists believe after this study
that it may even lead to neurogenesis,
which is a regrowth of
brain cells. And, um,
and in that study they gave rats,
they played this loud noise and then
they'd shock the hell out of these rats.
And then they gave some
of the routes psilocybin.
And then later on they played that noise
again and the rats that had psilocybin,
we're less likely to face
the fear of that sound.
And they believe that that was because
potentially it had led to the regrowth of
brain cells and the re reparation of the
serotonergic system that's so intense.
And this is something that we're saying
is illegal and if it's scheduled one.
So that means it has no medicinal
benefits. It's uh, addictive,
but they've proven mushrooms
aren't addictive. And,
and look at all of these studies
coming out showing that Psilocybin has
potential to cure anxiety and PTSD.
And so it's really,
it's just really disturbing.
But I recommend anyone out
there facing, you know,
who has a type of illness or
PTSD, depression, anxiety,
and they haven't found
any hope in anything else.
And if they're feeling hopeless to
just research psilocybin because it,
it gives me so much hope and I think
it's one of the greatest human rights
tragedies of our generation,
that this isn't available to
everyone who needs it. Uh,
it is very strange,
isn't it?
It's strange that a person like us
to come along and, and sort of like,
let people know about this. Like
the, this isn't common knowledge.
This isn't something that's
being taught in schools.
This isn't something the
president's talking about.
Like I have found a way to world
peace and we all need to do mushrooms.
Yeah. But it's, I mean, could
you imagine how many people,
and not everybody, this isn't for
everyone. Some people, you know what,
it potentially have bad trips
if you're not ready for it, but,
but the healing potential is so
great that it's worth the risk.
Um, yeah, I agree. I, and I also
think that, um, when you, uh,
when we go deep into the idea that
silicide and may have been responsible for
the very evolution of the human mind
itself, uh, it gets really compelling.
We had Dennis Mckenna on
the podcast and I'm going,
we're doing some emails back
and forth right now. I'm, uh,
I'll have him on hopefully
a in April again. But, um,
he explained in a very scientific manner
the actual correlation between use of
Psilocybin in the development of language.
Why there's a connection
and why it makes sense.
And based on the reaction to silicide and
by the human brain and the connections
that it makes. And I can't do it
justice to try to repeat what he said,
but it's incredibly compelling.
And his brother had Terrence.
Terrence Mckenna had this idea that
was in, in really intoxicating,
and that was the idea of the stoned ape,
the stoned ape theory being that when
climate change occurred and the rain
forest started to see receding into
grasslands, that these undulate cows is,
these wild cattle would leave
these shifts and these animals,
these monkeys would come along and
flip the shit's over and find bugs and
mushrooms that grow on the shifts.
So they would experiment with these
mushrooms and he had all these direct
correlations between experimented with
mushrooms and the improvement of various
acts aspects of life,
which would make it probable
that these people, these animals,
these humanlike things experimented
with these mushrooms including eating
visual, uh, the, uh, eating of
silicide increases low level,
a low level doses, increases
visual acuity. So it actually
makes you see better.
It makes edge detection better.
It would make you more effective hunter
and makes you more sensitive to your
environment. Uh, it would make you
hornier so he would have more sex. Um,
and of course then at higher doses
you would get this sort of unifying
experience that would
bomb the tribe together.
It would create a tighter group of people,
a tighter group of monkey, like people,
whatever the fuck they were.
And he used that as a direct reason
for one of the biggest mysteries in the
entire fossil record,
which is the doubling of the human brain
size over a period of 2 million years.
It's a really fascinating mystery
that no one has ever solved.
They don't know why.
There's a lot of theories.
There's a lot of competing theories as
to what caused the human brain size to
double. But it's an unprecedented event.
And biology, the way Mckenna described it,
he's like,
if it was like the liver of an otter,
it would be a spectacular find that our
liver of an odd or doubled over a period
of 2 million years. I mean, it
would be really perplexing. Like,
why is this when you have the greatest
transformation of any known biological
creature over a period of 2 million years
like this and that's the same Oregon
that created the theory of
evolution in the first place.
That's when shit gets really weird.
Like the human mind is the thing that's
figuring this all out and the human mind
is the thing that's doubling over the
period of this one is one period of time.
Well,
what else is going on?
And he pointed to all these factors
that pointed to the experimenting with
Psilocybin. It's really interesting
stuff. And then with his brother Dennis,
who's like a hardcore scientist explaining
the actual connections between eating
psilocybin and the possible creation of
language and of course the exponential
effect that creating language would have
on these animals and how that would,
it would,
it would force their mind to expand.
It would force along with the
psychedelic experiences there,
their boundaries to shift.
It's pretty incredible too to,
if you think on that theory to think
now what are we losing because we don't
have access as as as
person now we're sick.
We don't have our medicine. There's
this thing that's created us. Yeah.
And he also, Mckenna was really
into the eye. Well he's, uh,
he had a couple of freak ideas to,
one of them was a,
this longing for this orgiastic
nonmonogamous culture of the past.
Yeah.
Dude's always find a way to work that in
even the most spiritual guys find a way
to work out this nonmonogamous concept,
the mindsets to his girlfriend,
but his behavior, well in a sense
he's right, you know, as far as
male programming. But uh, you
know, it's, it's fascinating.
It's fascinating the concept behind
it that these, at one point in time,
these cultures supposedly all engaged
in this nonmonogamous saliva and Chris
Ryan is very interesting thoughts on
that as well. The Guy Rode, um, um, uh,
sex at dawn, brilliant guy who I
do a podcast with once a month.
Him and Duncan Trussell and I do a
podcast and these ideas were that at one
point in time there was no
sense of paternity that no
one knew that amber lines
baby came from Jamie. You know,
do you guys didn't, you know,
because everybody was having sex with
everybody and there was no DNA test.
So if you were having sex with five
different friends at the same time and all
of a sudden you've got pregnant,
everybody would raise the baby together.
And that would be the idea is that people
would grow accustomed to that sort of
a culture and that culture that makes
love together and has sex with more than
one partner. They, they
like each other more.
And one of the things that he uses to
sort of highlight that his wife swapping
amongst fighter pilots apparently
is very high. It's, it's a,
it's a normal concept.
And the idea being that you know,
that it's very likely you're going to
die out there and you love your wife and
you don't want your wife to be
with someone who doesn't love her.
And so by sharing her
with all your friends,
you leave behind someone who loves
your wife as equally as you do.
And then it's that intense of a shift
in the way you view the world, you know?
Um,
but I think that we just real stuck on
the idea that the way we live right now,
this is, this is the pattern that
we're all supposed to follow.
And this pattern may very
well be a pattern that's
separate from what created it
in the first place, which might be
psychedelic drugs. It might be the thing,
I mean even like mainstream Jerusalem
scholars now are saying that they believe
that Moses finding the 10 commandments
from a burning Bush was most likely at
some sort of a description
of a psychedelic experience.
And that the bush that's burning may
very well have been the Acacia Bush,
which is incredibly rich and DMT.
So one of the most DMT
rich in the entire region.
So if that is the burning Bush,
if that's the,
and the analogy that they're making,
you know, Moses sees the burning Bush,
is that what they're really saying?
Because we're getting information Hebrew,
we're getting your from Aramaic
translated to Latin, translated to Greek.
Is that you?
Sure that's what they're saying.
Cause what they might be saying as they
smoke some fucking dn and talk to God.
And God gave him some rules that really
made sense as to how we should live our
lives.
And if you look at the
Good Friday experiment,
I don't know if you're familiar with that,
that took place in Harvard when
they were studying psilocybin. Uh,
they gave theology students a high doses
of psilocybin and they all reported
having similar religious experiences
as to those described in the Bible.
And so,
so you kind of have to look back now that
I've been investigating psychedelics a
lot because I've had my own religious
experience where I've felt like I've been
given messages from God
or a higher being and,
and they tend to be similar to those
passed down throughout history. So you,
you kind of wonder how much did
psychedelics play a role and,
and our creation of religion.
Um, next time you come in or if
you can get it, if you can find it,
you got to pick up John. Marco OLED grows,
uh, the sacred mushroom in the cross.
Okay. Next time you come in, if you
come in again, remind me and I'll,
I'll give it to you.
You can borrow it.
It's hard to get because it's out of print
because the Catholic Church bought up
the rights for the book and it's
scooped it up and stopped it.
But there is one that you
still can get this in print.
It's called the Dead Sea Scrolls in the
Christian myth. Oh, well, you know what?
Wait a minute.
I should change that.
Yon Urban started republishing the
sake and mushroom and the cross.
So you see you can still get it.
And that's a really awesome
of him that he did that.
I don't know how he went about
getting the rights to that,
but it used to be that it was
a very difficult book to get,
but it's basically by a guy who,
this guy decipher the Dead
Sea scrolls for 14 years.
This Guy John Mark or rec allegro and
wrote a book on his interpretations of
what the language that he had read and
he said that he was the only one that was
an ordained minister,
but he was also agnostic.
He was the only one in
the Dead Sea Scrolls.
That was an agnostic that was in the
committee for deciphering it and his
interpretation of the Bible after 14
years of studying the Dead Sea scrolls was
that the entire religion was
a massive misunderstanding.
It was really originally about was
fertility rituals and the consumption of
psychedelic mushrooms and that these,
these allegories and these stories
and all these, these different,
these different parables,
they were designed to hide the true
nature of the knowledge that they didn't
want passed onto the Romans when they were
conquered. They didn't want passed on.
They wanted to hide it in stories and
that this is what the apple of Adam and
Eve was about and this was this,
this rebirth of the understanding of
the universe that would exist if you had
taken mushrooms,
you've taken psychedelic mushrooms was
what they were describing and all these
various stories and all these
different events. They were,
they were essentially trying to document
the knowledge that they had received
from having these psychedelic trips
and it's unbelievably intense when you,
you read that and then put it into
play and then start thinking like, oh,
wait a minute, I get it. These fucking
ancient people who knew nothing,
just stumbled upon this shit that made
literally made them who they were created
them and then all of a sudden
they realized it was going
away and whether it was
going away because of
additional climate change,
which they started losing mushrooms and
they started a preserving them in honey
and preserving them in honey also
started creating fermented honey,
which became need,
which is alcohol,
which led to more alcohol based society
and as they move slowly away from
mushrooms and slowly away
from psychedelic drugs,
they moved to like almost
an anti psychedelic and
alcohol and that's when Shit
went haywire.
It,
this disconnect from psychedelics was
what caused all these cultures to go
haywire.
It's really fascinating
and they religions have a,
a way of prosecuting psychedelic losers
are losers users throughout his charity.
That is the best like loser, but they
would call it the work of the devil.
And that's what I ran into
with the Mazza techs too.
I was working with up in Wahaca is that
they had to, when the Spaniards came,
they had to flee into the hills to
continue the mushroom tradition. Wow.
And now you'll actually
see, um, I went to San Jose,
Delpha Civica one town where the mushrooms
are readily accessible in this other
town.
What led de Jimenez and you'll see on
the churches they have Jesus and Mary.
And then on the other
side they have a mushroom.
So they actually warship the mushrooms.
They've kind of mixed I guess to survive.
They mixed Catholicism in with their
worship of these mushrooms. And um, it's,
it's pretty trippy per se to see
it painted on these churches.
That's actually a big part
of really ancient religious
artwork, period. You know,
a lot of, if you look in, look up,
do some research on the connection
between mushrooms and even the Catholic
church,
there's mushroom iconography all over the
place and really ancient descriptions.
Like one of the earliest depictions of
Adam and Eve on some ancient fresco is
Adam and eve with a mushroom
tree in between them. Have
you ever seen that image?
No. See if you can pull that up. Jamie,
Adam and Eve mushroom picture and uh,
we'll find the, a description
of it. Uh, and eve mushroom.
Yeah, we just lost track of all this
stuff. It's also one of the reasons. Yeah,
this is, it's right away. You could
pull up that image. It's pretty intense.
That's a, that's an image of Adam
and eve. I mean, look at that.
That's crazy. By the mushroom.
That's fucking crazy.
And it was really strange for me when I
was in Mexico to see them blessing the
mushrooms on the altar. A instead
of the communion, holy water,
they give you mushrooms and that's
your sacrament. That's what you eat.
There's another one and
Jamie pull up. There's the other, another
one that's a different image, but a very,
very similar image. See that one on the
far left, far left. Yeah, right there.
I click up that one.
Look at that.
Isn't that trippy? That's from 1147. Uh,
they call it CE now. They don't call
it a d anymore for whatever reason,
but that's from 1147.
So they just knew,
even back then about psychedelic plants
having some sort of a connection to
Christianity. And these were, you know,
these were from churches. So it's, um,
it's really fascinating.
That's just something that went away.
It was something that was a part,
the doorways,
the shape of the doorway being very
mushroom. Like in a lot of these,
they look like a mushroom
cap, you know, that's like,
there's didn't choose that for,
you know, it wasn't an accident.
There was a guy jack hair, and before
he, um, he had a stroke and then he went,
was eventually had a heart
attack and went up dying.
And he was a very important part of the
hemp movement in letting people know he
was a Goldwater Republican.
And, uh, he, uh,
he wrote a book called the
emperor has no clothes about, uh,
about marijuana and the real root of
the propaganda that allowed marijuana to
become an illegal drug and his thing, and
he was working on, before he got sick,
it was all on the connections between
silicide and religious, uh, religious,
uh, thought religions period,
that creation of religions.
And he had some really
amazing old paintings.
I wish I knew where he had
collected these, these images,
but of people lost in
like a dance of ecstasy.
Like they were naked and they were
covered by this translucent mushroom.
And it was a like a reoccurring theme
in like really ancient art work that was
religious artwork that these people were
engaging in ritualistic behavior with
psychedelics.
And it was a part of the church,
whether it was something that was
originally for everybody and then when it
became more scarce was
just controlled by the,
the upper crust of the religious
organization or you know, what,
what happened over how many periods
of hundreds if not thousands of years,
which is hard for us to
kind of let it sink in.
How much of a shift to a hundred
years can be, think about it this way,
200 years ago,
if you wanted a picture of something,
you had to draw it and if you
want to get around on something,
you had to ride an animal that's just
200 years ago, you know, 200 years ago,
slavery was legal and all those things.
So just wrap your head around that and
then try to move forward to thinking 200
years before that,
200 years before that.
And just thinking if at any
point in time during that period,
okay,
the pipeline gets cut off to the most
influential connection to spirituality
known to mankind.
And then people left a boom,
fend for themselves and figure things out.
And then the stories are
they'd go from these things,
which you have this repeatable connection
through ceremony to to the mother
earth, to the universe, to God
to love. And then no connection.
The connection is completely seven are
all you have is words describing this
connection.
Boy would take on a hollow tone.
And then all of our primate behavior and
instincts and all the shitty aspects of
human beings,
control and ego would flourish and rise
to the top and even be fed by alcohol,
which is the anti psychedelic.
And then culture is left with these,
these words,
these hollow words written on animal
skins from back when people were,
even then when they
wrote these things down,
probably grasping to the last remaining
fibers of this former existence that
they had in symbiosis
with the plant knowledge.
Isn't that the irony?
Humor in the universe that so many people
spend their entire lives searching for
this religious experience.
Thousands and thousands of dollars.
And you can get it for
free growing on cow shit.
And isn't it funny that when someone
wants to call you on your nonsense,
they call you on your bullshit? Yeah,
yeah. Oh, that is such bullshit.
It's like there's nothing that's going
to let you see what's bullshit and not
bullshit like mushrooms.
Exactly.
And I think we've had the push towards
legalization of marijuana and I think the
next big movement should be to legalize
mushrooms. I mean they grow everywhere.
They're a natural product there.
They've been proven, as I said before,
not to be addictive.
They're not neurotoxic.
Your caffeine in your coffee's more
toxic on your body and your system.
So why not develop that next push for,
for mushroom legalization?
I couldn't agree more and I think what
we need to do is it needs to be done in
like a, a professional
setting. Like hire people,
like they have really acclaimed Iowasca
arrows that everybody loves and goes to
figure out a way to hire someone and
have someone run a mushroom center like
that.
A person who is an experienced voyager,
a person who's pure and their
intent and they can help people.
And what an unbelievably rewarding life
that would be for someone who instead
would be worrying about their physical
safety in performing these things.
You'd have to do that
under, under, you know,
secret conditions to hide from people and
someone have to look out the window to
make sure the jackbooted thugs don't
kick down the door and stopped them when
they're in the middle of enlightenment,
you know,
and arrest them and go throw them in
some rat infested fucking cage somewhere.
To not have to worry about that.
And to be able to,
to actually give people
this experience in a, in a,
in a real pure setting would be pretty
nice. And this is where people go fool.
Good. So Soutar Rogan is flipping
slogan. Dope talk. I get it.
I'm tired of me too man.
I'm tired of me too.
It, it's so profound in what the
mushrooms did for me and what they do.
I think they're,
they can be so effective,
especially for women in traditionally
psychedelics have been more of a,
a male discussion topic. But
I think women, I will admit,
I think they may even need them more
because we tend to be more self critical
than men are. And so that's a
prefrontal cortex being overactive.
And so that leads to depression. And
anxiety and what the silicide and does,
they've actually done scans of brains
when people are on psilocybin is it
decreases the blood flow, that area
of your brain. So that for once,
and this is what happened for me,
is finally everything just went
silent and it was so profound.
I just burst into tears and I just could
not stop crying because I hadn't had
silence for so long. And at that
point, because I had that silence,
I was able to go back and rewatch my life
like a movie and see all these things
that had happened over just the span of
two years and then slowly realized, okay,
that's why I'm was in
the position I was in.
And I was able to reprocess all of these,
all of these stored memories.
And if you look at women of,
what is it,
one fourth of women in their forties
and fifties are on some kind of
antidepressant.
That's just a bandaid on a bullet wound.
And I felt like the mushrooms
actually got in to my soul and,
and cured and helped. Um,
perfect. My limbic system,
which is what Western
medicine is ignoring.
That is a really strange number,
isn't it?
One quarter of people are on
antidepressants over x amount of age.
I've always wondered why it is women
are uniquely drawn to those things after
they get to be a certain age. Like what
is it? What is it about antidepressants?
This is a quick specs maybe.
Is that what it is? Is it a, a,
a biological issue that comes with their,
their body's slowing down and they become
less and less happy and uh, you know,
maybe that could be something that
could be altered by exercise or by,
you know, like a man can stimulate as
testosterone with squats and, you know,
there's various, you know,
hormonal ways they could do
that. But the women, do they,
do they have anything out
there that expands your,
your natural female sexual hormones?
Does, is there anything that does do that?
I think there are hormone replacements.
Right? But I don't know of any natural,
maybe so.
Yeah.
But I would wonder that at a certain point
if their body just slows down so much
that they just feel shitty,
you know,
they're just not producing
hormones correctly anymore.
And that's what leads them to try to
find happiness in a pill that they need
something that gives them like a little,
a little serotonin boost, you know?
And what's so sad is that uh,
a lot of times with these medicines,
not all of them,
but it's actually permanently changing
your serotonin levels and depleting them.
So you are dependent on these medicine.
Just to get back to where you were
when you started taking it. Saint
those medicines are really
important for some people though.
That's where it gets real sketchy
because I don't want to write off
antidepressants because I know
people that have benefited from them.
The question is, would they have benefited
equally well from something else?
Some people may be,
I know some dudes that have actually
gotten on them and then to help their life
and then they slowly wean themselves off,
you know?
And then I know also people that they
benefited from the natural way of doing it
by taking five HTP and finding that
that gave them an elevated mood.
And then exercise is a big one.
They've also done studies that show that
exercise rigorous exercise is equally
effective for increasing
happiness as aren't some people.
So it's like how do you know?
I know personally guys have
benefited from antidepressant,
so you can't say this guy shouldn't take
it because I don't know what's going on
in his head. You know, and
I'm not understand the,
the actual science behind it all.
I can parrot it,
but I don't really understand what the
fuck is going on like comprehensively.
And I think that you would have to
really study it for a long time to really
understand it comprehensively, but I think
there should be more than one option.
That's my point.
My point is it's real problematic when
you got something like partnership for a
drug free America and they get money
for pharmaceutical companies to go after
other drugs. I mean, it's one of the
most hilarious aspects of our culture,
but the fact is that alcohol companies
paid for ads against marijuana and that
that's a fact. That's what a partnership
for a drug free America entails.
Prescription drug companies, alcohol
companies, all paid part of that.
It's just ridiculous.
So it should be,
there should be a bunch of
different options available.
Exactly.
That's why I'm trying to talk about my
story with psychedelic use and how much
it helped me just so people know when
the other options haven't worked. Um,
like you said, Joe, I'm not discounting.
I'm sure a lot of people have
been helped from pharmaceuticals,
but I think some people have tried
them and because it is the only option,
they feel like, oh my
gosh, it's, this is it.
And that's why so many of these soldiers
who have post traumatic stress disorder
end up taking their own lives.
And I interviewed one soldier
who was at that point,
he had been on antidepressants and
nothing was working. He was having,
he had a panic attack that sent him to
the emergency room and almost killed him
because his heart rate was so quick.
And um,
and luckily he heard about Mtma and
psilocybin and went to a concert and got
some wow. And that was, uh, had profound
effects. He wasn't able to be in crowds.
And then within weeks he was
able to go back out into society.
And now he actually takes
the mushrooms and travels,
he's like an underground railroad of
psychedelics between soldiers and he
travels around the country,
uh,
a dosing his buddies so that they
can kind of get out of this Rut.
Those that haven't been helped
by anti depressants. Wow.
And the Mtma his shows you, I know you
talk with Rick Doblin allotted just so,
such profound promise that in one
study they had people who had treatment
resistant PTSD.
So nothing was working.
And 83% of the people in this study
who were given Mtma combined with
psychotherapy, uh, no longer
had the symptoms of post
traumatic stress disorder,
whereas 25% of people who just were
given psychotherapy were healed. So,
I mean that's a pretty
profound numbers there and
numbers. Could you imagine if that
number was any other sort of medication?
Exactly. Every doctor be prescribing
it to you, they'd be a no brainer.
You'd go to the doctor and they would
immediately prescribed it to you.
We have 22 soldiers a day killing
themselves needlessly, Joe. And that,
that weighs on my shoulders
now. Cause I, I did,
I was never officially with posttraumatic
stress disorder. But I do know,
especially after talking
with a lot of these soldiers,
I was having symptoms of it and
knowing how profoundly effective the
psychedelics were on helping me and,
and curing my anxiety and letting me
process those traumatic memories. Um,
it's so sad to know that there's so
many people out there that haven't been
connected with this medicine
yet or are being misled.
And in the United States government knows
that Mtma they've been told many times
they'd been shown the
results of this study. Uh,
the Pentagon knows that it's effective.
Why? Why hasn't it been legalized?
Well, because someone can profit
from it not being legalized.
It's the only reason. And it's too
easy to grow. That's the problem.
These drugs that are really,
really beneficial,
boy does nature make them
readily available because
nature wants us to take them.
[inaudible] need to knows we're insane.
You could drive if,
especially if you live in a nice place
like Seattle where it rains a lot.
You could drive down the street,
throw pot seeds out the window,
just throw him as you drive and then
come back a couple months later and poppy
growing everywhere, it would be
unavoidable. It's that easy. You know?
It's like we were all right,
dude. Hey, you need fertilizer,
do you? Nope. Nope, nope,
nope. Don't need anything. Don't worry
about me. I'll just go right here.
The best things in life are free. It's,
it's for sure, and I'm a firm believer
or that nature has created.
Uh, I used to be a skeptic,
but now I am a believer that nature has
created something to heal all of our
ailments. And we just need to
be connected with that. And,
and we need to realize that sometimes
it's the more natural route that's more
effective versus going
the pharmaceutical route.
And oftentimes the pharmaceutical route
is sort of based on something that came
from the natural route in the
first place. I mean the, the, the,
the lessons learned from using natural
materials sometimes. I mean, one of the,
one of the things, one thing that
they want to do so much in the jungle,
they want to extract pharmaceutical
drugs out of these jungle plants.
And that's a big reason why there's so
much exploration in the jungle besides
using all the wood,
you know,
that they're clear cutting
giant chunks of that forest.
One of the things that the medical
community is really concerned about when
they're doing that is that
when they're clear cutting,
I mean they're destroying ecosystems
and when they're destroying ecosystems,
we know there are hundreds of thousands
of different types of plants down there
and we have no idea if the cure to cancer
is not locked up at some weird fucking
bury that no one has ever discovered.
We just don't know. And it might be,
it really might be. They found his fucking
spider, the Brazilian wandering spider,
and they're trying to use it
for a better viagara cause this,
the spider is the most poisonous spider.
The Vera found kills
you and when kills you.
One of the ways that kills you is with
an erection that is unbelievably painful.
Literally breaks the skin on your penis.
So even if you get through it,
which many people don't fights
you and then you get this
erection, you get it, it,
it affects somehow or another the
nitric oxide production of your body and
you're in,
it injects you with something that does
something to the whole mechanism and
your whole body becomes unbelievably
painful and rigid and you get an erection.
And the erection is like,
have you ever thrown a hot dog on a grill?
And he's it plumps and then it pops.
Yeah, that's you. That's your penis.
It plumps and it's apparently it breaks
it if you live, even if you live,
your sexuality is ruined.
You're never having your Dick is broken.
It doesn't work anymore.
I get red lines,
that thing until piston start
farming out of the sides of it.
So even if you do survive,
you're broken. And they,
so they found this fucking creepy spider
and they're trying to figure out how to
make like the best hard
on pill ever with this.
Like forget about Viagara like we're
talking, you just need like a molecule,
this shit thrown in your system
and you have erections on demand.
It's like I was thinking of nature
has a, a cure for everything. Even uh,
there's this one shaman in the Amazon
in his entire village was sick and he
couldn't cure them. And so he thought his
entire tribe was going to be wiped out.
So legend has it.
He drank IOWASCA and walked into the
jungle and these hands came out and showed
him this frog,
which is the Kambo frog.
It's the most poisonous frog in the
jungle and showed him how to kind of milk
the frog and then put it,
apply the poison to the
people in the village to,
to cure what was ailing them.
And he was able to,
as legend has it curious
how his whole village,
well now this Kambo frog venom
is used as a vaccination.
So instead of the traditional vaccinations
we give here in the u s they use this
frog venom to vaccinate the children and
also to make the men stronger as they
hunt.
And I actually got it at w and what they
do is they just kind of cauterize your
arm and put a little on you and right
away you feel like you're being poisoned.
So your whole body reacts to produce
all of these antibodies and an emergency
effort to try to save your life.
And you just feel the blood pounding
through your head and it's almost,
it's so intense.
It's like going,
you feel like it will shoot
through your fingertips and Oh,
and like all these frogs are
running through you and your,
your lips start to swell and
you're sitting there thinking,
am I really going to die? Like,
what the hell did I just take that,
that I was thinking at
the time? And then, um,
you just v violently vomit after that.
Like from the depths of your soul and
all of these toxins leave your body.
And after going through this for about
an hour, you just feel miraculous like,
like all of the toxins been pulled out
to you and you feel energy from months to
come because your body is produced all
these antibodies to fight infection.
And I got it done about three months
ago and, and I, I feel great, you know,
whether I'd recommend it to everybody,
but that's just frog venom, you know,
a natural substance and
the environment and,
and they say it potentially has promised
to for HIV patients because of the
flood of antibodies and other people
facing autoimmune disorders. We, which,
um, you know, I, I believe it
could potentially have that effect.
It seems like it,
if it doesn't really poison you but it
fires all your systems on go like red
alert, you know, we were being poisoned
and it produces all these, like dr crawl
heart was saying compensatory mechanisms
that that might be beneficial to
increasing your health.
Totally kind of makes sense.
And I, like I said, I
feel great. Like I've,
I felt like I've had more energy since,
since I've done it.
It might just be a placebo
then we'll see how it works.
That's the problem. Some way.
Great guy that was
telling the healing God,
it was like pressing on
your back when I was like,
how has this word it just plain it
when he was explaining that it's like a
placebo. Pardon me? It was
like bitch, shut the fuck up.
But then the other part of me was like,
but wait a minute.
Placebo effects do well.
So you almost have to be dumb enough to
believe this guy for his stuff to work.
But what is it that's working?
Like how is it that's working and when
you talk to the Shamans that we're legit,
like you know you had the one guy that
likes to grab you but then you pass that
guy and there's this other
guy who's like totally legit.
Did you ever ask him how
they figure this stuff out?
How they figured out I Ohio Wasco?
Like what is the explanation?
How do they figure out how to add
all these thousands of plants,
brew these two together and doing a really
complicated process that takes a long
time to get this one thing
and it tastes like shit.
And yet they drank it anyway and then
have these experiences like how the fuck
did they ever figure that out?
It's not like they had microscopes,
botanists, um, apparently it was
brought to them by, by the spirits.
That's the universal
story I've heard from,
from every Shawman is that
somehow they were visited by, um,
spirits or beings that then showed
them to combine, combine these two,
um, the Iowasca vine and the Chacruna
leaves out of thousands and thousands of,
of species.
Other people say that it's mother
nature's way of fighting back against the
insanity of mankind.
Wow.
That I you ask is actually
was made by the plants and,
and somehow that plant spirit was given
to the people to show them how to make
it and buy some beliefs.
The ius,
got to know if you're
familiar with epigenetics,
but when you have a lot of trauma,
it actually changes your DNA and it
makes you more prone to be depressed or,
or insane. And so, uh,
by some shamans beliefs that WASC is
actually getting in one man at a time and
restructuring our DNA and getting rid
of all of this negative epigenetics and,
and just, it's just mother nature's way
of fighting back against the insanity.
And so, so I get different stories
from every, every Shawman but the,
the epigenetics one tends to be the more
a common denominator that I've heard
from several of them that they believe
it is actually mother nature fighting
back and trying to, uh, heal
us, heal our limbic systems.
So we don't have this
collective madness anymore.
One person at a time who knows
how long that's going to take.
They're on a different time schedule.
Maybe it's a thousand years, but,
but it is working one person at a time.
You know,
I've met people who've had profound,
uh, miracles on these substances.
I've also met people who haven't, you
know, but it's not for schizophrenia.
It's not for people using antidepressants.
You have to make sure you're
off the medicines. It could,
it could kill you. Um,
but uh, that's important point. Yeah.
And a lot of they do when people
go down there, if, uh, they,
they're on antidepressants. Do
People like that? They ask, they do,
they make it really clear
and then they ask a every,
how long do you have to get off of it for,
I don't know the exact,
that's something it'd be worth googling.
But you can't be on anti depressants.
IOWASCA does not like antidepressants.
That's very important there folks. Yeah,
very important. And also people who
are prone to have schizophrenia, um,
the IOWASCA in psychedelics in general
tend to allow that to come on earlier.
It doesn't mean it would have already
happened. It doesn't cause schizophrenia,
you are already going to get it.
But because the psychedelic might
actually make it come on, uh,
a couple days earlier or a couple of days,
a couple of years earlier,
and I was even next to
one woman in a ceremony.
He was having a schizophrenia episode
a while on the medicine and it was,
it was pretty,
pretty terrifying and so reaffirmed my
belief to make sure to mention to people,
you know, certain people,
the medicines aren't made for
Mckenna had Terence Mckenna had another
interesting way of looking at the
development of these things,
the development of things like a Iosco
that these people that lived in these
indigenous cultures,
they didn't have metallurgy and they
did have an advanced social system.
So as they went through hundreds and then
thousands of years of the same culture
evolving the way they spread
out and their knowledge base,
it didn't go to architecture.
It didn't go to the construction of large
buildings or airplanes or machines or
engines. It went instead plants and
that their knowledge base and the,
the, the, the,
the information that they passed down
from generations to generations and
they're expanding on the ideas
that they currently were aware of,
all involved nature. It's really kind
of a fascinating way to look at it.
It's just when you know
Europeans were going this way,
they were going a different way,
but the same process seems to exist in
every human culture that people start at
one point wherever they are at
and then they started advancing.
They started advancing, figuring things
out, adding to their knowledge base,
but these people, they did an all
entirely in a natural setting.
They never changed the setting.
The setting was always like huts and
things and living amongst the animals and
the being a part of this whole
nature thing. And then in doing so,
communicating in some way,
shape or form with this spirit world,
whether it's through eating mushrooms
and tripping and then taking back some of
that information and applying it,
whatever it was that the plants talk to
them and gave them this information and
then they figured out how to pass it
on through generation to generation and
explain this is what you
use when you get burnt.
This is what you use when that
this can send you to Jupiter.
I agree that nature has something for
every single element that we face.
And,
and what's so sad to mentioning that
about the indigenous cultures living close
to nature,
actually connecting with this healing
energy is how much we've come apart from
that, especially here in Los
Angeles. He know, you think, um,
there's this website I was
looking on a couple of weeks ago,
like earthing.com where people are
actually so disconnected from nature that
they're buying earthing mats,
um,
that have like a wire connected out
to the backyard under their beds.
If you think about it
too, like some people, uh,
something I've been trying to
do is just go around barefoot,
walk through the grass, really try
to connect with the earth, you know,
to allow that energy and
knowledge to go through you.
But some people might spend years
without their feet actually touching the
earth.
And it's just so crazy to think how far
we've become removed from nature that we
have to buy earthing mats to put in
our beds or put, put under your, uh,
your, your chair while you're at
your computer. That's pretty stupid.
It's just we've just lost this connection
and I think in the process we've lost
our sanity and we need to get that
back and that's why we need to start
reevaluating these plants and start
integrating them into our culture and,
and start really waking
up to how ridiculous these
laws are that you're making
mother nature illegal. You're telling
me a mushroom that grows on couch.
It all across the world is
illegal. Yeah, it's dangerous
and it just is. It's, it's insane.
There's also the feeling that
you get when you're in the woods.
That's a palpable,
real feeling of being connected to nature.
This is a calming effect of
walking through the woods.
Like you go on a hike through the woods,
you're walking,
there's all these beautiful
trees and you see everything.
It's like you feel different.
You feel different because
you're in the vibe of nature.
You're like immersed in this world.
That really doesn't give a shit about you.
I mean, you're there. You're not
there. If this is the world, I mean,
it is what it is. It's not dependent on
you to hit the light switch. It just is.
You know, it will be here before
you, it will be here after you.
It just is what it is.
Trees and animals are running by and
we sort of affected by our presence,
but we're a part of it when we're in
it. And when you're in it, you feel it.
And we kind of,
we've removed all that.
We put a buildings and fence and a fucking
highway and made everything hard and
we've sort of separated ourselves from
this really intense connection to nature.
And I think that we could never really
understand what it's like to have an
unbroken, you know, maybe a thousand,
maybe 2000 year connection and the
culture that you're immersed in,
the culture that you
live in to that world,
and that's what those people are
experiencing that live in the jungle that
created Iowasca.
They're experiencing this long unbroken
connection to the actual mother itself.
And it could be, that's why we
have so many mental health issues,
which don't exist in these indigenous
cultures. Exactly. And even in the areas,
the towns we went to that
rely on medicinal mushrooms,
they don't use antidepressants.
Instead,
when they're having grief or they're
having a traumatic event, their life,
they eat some mushrooms and go into the
mountains or visit one of these healers.
And, and so you look at the
rates of happiness in these,
these villages,
in these areas compared to what we're
experiencing here in the United States.
And you have to think to yourself,
they must be doing something right.
We should at least examine,
uh,
what they're using over over our
system that that's not working.
Yeah, no kidding. Um, uh,
I'm, I'm really very, uh,
I'm very hopeful, uh, sometimes
ridiculously so about the human race.
And part of it become, comes from
my own personal experiences like a,
I really enjoy life. I really
do. I really enjoy my friends.
I really enjoy what I'm doing. So
I'm, I'm very positive in that way.
I'm not ignorant to the ways of the world.
I'm not ignorant to the news.
But I also am not ignorant
to the perspective of 7
billion people being alien to
one individual,
7 billion people's problems all lumped
up into your fucking head because you
went online,
stayed on too many websites and read
too much shit and watch too many videos.
That's not how you're
supposed to experience the
world like we're not designed
for that interface.
The interface were designed for is the
interface you experience when you go on a
hike through the woods,
what what you encounter is what is real
in your own perceptions. These are,
these are the things that you can effect.
These are the things that you can change,
but that's all changed itself by having
the ability to communicate and influence
all these different people.
With your story, like you,
what you're telling right here,
what you told in your book,
what you told when you
first came on the podcast,
but your experience working for a news
organization that it seems in in least
during the time that you were there to
have lost its way and where this created
turmoil and your, your own
personal experience index
by expressing those things,
you're literally changing everything
around you. You're really,
you literally effecting everything around
you with the experiences that you've
had and forcing change and you're forcing
it even more right now whether you
realize it or not,
probably more so even tenfold than the
last time you were on because you're
telling me you're saying some crazy shit,
you know,
are a mainstream CNN reporter and now
you're some crazy tripper who travels the
globe eating mushrooms and doing
payoti buttons and freaking out.
I just feel like such a duty
to deliver this message.
And I know I'm taking a risk and I know
there'll be some people who criticize me.
The camp though, Carl Hart had
a great point yesterday. Um, uh,
I keep bringing him up just
cause he's awesome. But, um,
one of the things you said, he said
if I have the data, um, um, I'll,
I'll debate anyone. I have the
data and if I don't have the data,
you're not gonna hear me talking about it.
But if I have the data,
the data's on my side. I'm
very confident. And the data,
clearly your personal data is undeniable.
And just my own,
my own story from where I was then
pre psychedelic to where I am now.
I feel like I've had a complete
rebirth and data. It's my data.
I feel like it's near.
I literally feel like my serotonergic
system has been restructured and I find it
nearly impossible to get anxiety.
And this is coming from someone who
used to have constant butterflies in my
stomach. I have near panic attacks
and I just don't feel that anymore.
And so you have to say, okay, what,
what, what did I change in my life? Well,
that was the psychedelic use. That was
the, the main treatment I used, uh,
to, to overcome this. And I,
I just feel, I, I feel like
it could help so many women,
especially because like I was saying
earlier about them being so self critical
and,
and really just so many people who just
haven't taken the time to stand outside
of their life and analyze it objectively
and make decisions not based on emotion
or being self critical.
You know?
It's kind of amazing if this was like a
product that we were trying to sell you
like the best celebrity spokesperson,
right.
Ever. That's like, you're
like, I'm going to get,
I feel like I just feel like whoever
doesn't like my message is going to come
try to just like smear my
credibility and everything.
They can't, they can't, they can't. They
can't until they experience it themselves.
They can. And once they do, they
wouldn't, people who don't know,
people who really have no idea.
If they did mushrooms and they had
that experience, they would go,
oh wow. I didn't even know. Yeah.
You know, how could you know?
I don't even blame them.
I don't blame them for being skeptical.
I think it's important,
but I almost feel bad if they don't know.
And I think you kind of must feel the
same way because I can tell that you're
very compelled.
Talk about this.
And you took a long time to decide
to gonna go public about this.
You know, we had conversations
about this quite a long time ago.
Yeah.
A year ago.
That's when I was coming back from
Iowasca and I wrote you and just thank you
for introducing me and told you how
everyone go check out this crazy.
Yeah,
bitch.
She listened to me.
Yeah. But I, I turns out
I actually, I was right.
And then, and then after then
I had, after the Iowasca,
I went to Thailand where
I was able to access, um,
psilocybin mushrooms that grow on
elephant and, um, buffalo poop.
And they're are just so amazingly
healing. And, and so I wrote,
wrote you after that.
But I took time to actually discuss it
because I really needed to try to absorb
as much knowledge as I could
from the plants and really, um,
figure them out journalistically.
Like I was on one path of healing.
And also another path as a journalist
and I just wanted to experience the good
trips and experienced the bad trips and
really figure out what these medicines
are about. Um, before I
came forward with my story,
because I know some people may hear this
and then decide to try psychedelics and
so I needed to be 100% sure I was
on the right path, which I know now.
Now you not only are on
the right path you feel,
but you also are putting other
people on this path. You,
you created this crazy website, so
explain your website. Yes. The claim,
what you're doing
now. What happened was when I started
researching about Iowasca and stuff,
like I said, I went to a center that
I wasn't, I couldn't really trust.
I noticed there wasn't a lot of websites
out there that could connect people
with knowledge about these psychedelics.
Also,
I noticed there wasn't a lot
of psychedelic journalism
because there's not a lot
of experienced journalists or it's just
not being funded or I mean a various
amount of factors that pretty
awesome airways. Amazing. Yeah. Yeah.
One of the most important resources for
anybody that is interested in any of the
effects of any of these psychedelic
experiences, drugs, medicines,
whatever you want to call them,
compounds era would is one of the best
erowid.org right.org and also maps.org.
They're both fantastic to go and find
out about research studies and um,
and, and just read other people's a
trip reports and experiences. And uh,
what I'm doing with this site is
creating like the Huffington post of
psychedelic news. So we're just going
to be focusing on the war on drugs, um,
accurate reporting, independent
reporting on these topics. Also,
we were building the foundation right now,
so we have like,
we want to make it like a virtual city
where people can come and sit down and
have a cup of coffee and chat with others
who've done it, uh, to reduce harm,
harm reduction also so people can find
accurate information and reviews of,
of different centers and,
and just find a,
we're going to take all these studies
that had been around since the 1950s and,
and send them back out to the public. So
they can get this information. And, um,
and I just think it's,
it's really vital right now
because when you Google news alert,
which I often do with all these
substances, I'll Google news or alert, um,
like ketamine,
which is profound.
It has profound effects on
depression and psilocybin.
And the stories that always come up are
the ones of the guy getting busted for
selling it or the rare festival death.
Rarely do you actually get news on,
on how these substances
are being used medicinally.
So that's what we're trying
to create with this new site.
reset.me reset.me.
Um,
what is it? What does
Emmy, it's another country
for this purposes. It's me as in resetting
yourself. Great Way to remember it.
reset.me. I mean, it's really perfect
name, but what country is it? It's, um,
that's a good question. We might want
to look that up. I should know that,
but I use it more in the,
uh,
I remember listening to talk of
Terence Mckenna's and he said that, uh,
using DMT in different psychedelics can
be like hitting the reset button on your
brain, clearing your hard
drive of all the trauma. And,
and I believe that's what
psychedelics did for me. I've,
I've heard you describe
them that way as well.
And so for people who really need to hit
that reset button in life and they've
tried other therapies
and that hasn't worked,
we're going to be providing journalism
on these psychedelic therapies and also
alternative non prescription
therapies. It's Montenegro, Montenegro,
Negro,
the government
of Montenegro. Okay. Hovey we're
not based in Montenegro, but um,
there's some, they sold the domain
name writes a lot of countries did for,
for sale and like Biz like,
you know, like there's a,
there's a bunch of them that they, uh,
they, they sold.us. You can get a dot.
You asked. You know, it's
interesting. Um, so that's awesome.
reset.me and a hasn't launched yet.
It hasn't launched yet.
It's still being built.
So it should launch within a month.
But once again, things change.
Sometimes if it takes a little long,
well you got to come on again
when it launches and let us know.
We'll tweet about it and
we'll let people know.
And we just talked for three hours
for sure.
And if anyone wants to go to reset.me,
you can follow all of our
social media accounts.
We're really looking for people
who are experienced users,
kind of the teachers who can come and,
and be there,
be waiting for the students and just
people who support our message and who are
interested in writing for us or
sharing their own stories of healing.
And how are you avoiding trolls,
you know, prepare. You just,
you just announced yourself to the world.
Look,
the people that listen to this
podcast are not universally cool.
There's a certain percentage of them
that are fucking trolls and they will
launch themselves upon you for uh,
you know,
in search of humor with with some really
fake fake profound tales of things
happening to them in the jungle and
guarantee you now it's going to be about
titty grabbing while you're out cold.
It's going to be,
there's going to be several,
several stories of what the
band was scary to me too late.
It's out there
I think for helping the
community will self regulate,
will give various people who there's
already people out there who I'm sure
you've interacted with Joe,
who have a reputable Twitter accounts
who've been really passionate about
psychedelics, who we've recruited to help
us in our forums and just help us out.
We also have a section on the site where
you can post links to different news
stories and stuff that
you find interesting.
So we have these people on board to help
us kind of regulate. That being said,
you can, you can't find everything,
so we're expecting you to come.
But we're,
so the team behind this,
we all met doing Iowasca and what we've
all been so profoundly affected that,
that we want to bring this new creation
forward to, to try to help others.
That's the new amber Lyon
tripping around the world number
one and version 2.0 reset.
Wow. Well, congratulations
on a congratulations on
everything, on your journey,
on this website and the whole thing.
I think you're a very brave person and I
thought you were very brave person when
you were talking about your experiences
at CNN and you stick your neck out,
you know, you really do. And so, uh,
it's cool to be your friend and it's cool
to watch all this happen and it's, uh,
it's cool to have you on the show.
Thank you very much. Thank you Jo.
It's such an honor has been a lot of
fun. Amber Lyon, ladies and gentlemen,
please follow amber on Twitter,
Amber Lyon on Twitter,
l y o n and uh, go to
the web set, reset.me.
It's reset.me and uh,
within a month or so
there'll be some shit up there. And, uh,
I'm sure amber will keep you posted on
Twitter and we'll keep you posted on
Twitter too. So thank you.
Thank you. Thank you everybody.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to the Lumosity, go
to lumosity.com/joe. Click
the start training button.
Start and start playing your first game,
that lumosity.com/joe Click
the start training button.
And thanks also to [inaudible]
dot com go to o n n I.
T he used the Codeword Rogan and
save 10% off any an all supplements.
Thanks also to legal zoom,
legal zoom.
Go to legal zoom.com and enter Rogan in
the referral box at checkout for more
savings. We'll be back in a little bit
with Matt, that terror, the terror,
Sarah and then uh, Thursday, uh,
Shane Smith from vice.com
we'll be here as well.
And we're going to have
a fucking great time.
We'll probably get drunk
so you soon much love.
Hm.